All right.
I think we're alive.
We're alive.
We're alive on Youtube.
How about that?
Uh,
I am here with author,
with journalists,
with documentary filmmaker and a guy who's gonna cause me a whole world eight
today,
Mike Cernovich.
How you doing man?
Um,
I'm doing better than you're doing.
That's really good.
Well,
I'll leave where you're in the bubble of protection right now.
So we'll see the battlement in the barrage of attacks coming.
Yeah.
Okay.
So look,
I you,
I think you know how I interview,
I really try to just sit down with someone and focus on being present and seeing
where the chips fall,
but I am going to conduct this interview a little bit differently than I usually
do.
I've got all your past controversies here and controversial statements and
things you've said and done and all of those things.
And I want to dive into all of those things.
But I thought the first thing we should do is talk a little bit about our
history because I had you on the show way before.
We were independent.
We were at aura TV back in March of 2016 it was right at the beginning of the
Trump phenomenon and I was seeing this thing on Twitter where I saw all this
support for Trump.
I saw these fun memes.
I saw like there was a real energy behind this thing,
but I could not find anyone,
you know,
a verified person on Twitter or a celebrity or an author.
I couldn't find anyone that was supporting Trump.
Then I came across you.
I think I tweeted out,
I'm looking for a Trump supporter basically to have on the show.
I came across you,
you are a published author.
You could have the gorilla mindset,
which you have right here,
and we sat down and three and a half years ago,
it feels like a different life to me.
Uh,
what,
what you,
what do you remember that guy three and a half year ago,
Mike Cernovich.
Well yeah,
that's what's wild.
And then people attack you because subsequent controversies arose at some of
which,
right.
Then you did things lead.
We're going to address them.
Ruben talked to two years.
How dare he talk us like,
well,
the character arc was different and the history of is pretty simple at the time
that I was on your show.
Everybody said Trump all went,
here's why.
Boom,
boom,
the Poles,
this everything.
And I said,
no,
no.
He's gonna win.
Here's why.
Here's the trends,
here's why people support some.
Here's where the puck is going.
As Wayne Gretzky was safe,
nobody else was saying that.
Nobody could.
Scott Adams being an exception cogently not,
oh I love Trump.
Robyn,
Robyn.
No.
The media has made him everything.
Now that I'm saying the media is like catching up to oh,
Trump's nicknames,
maybe we shouldn't amplify them.
A two powerful everything where I talked about branding,
how Trump was essentially the big gorilla and everything else.
So all of that aged well.
Everything that I said was going to happen happened and then people go,
well we don't want to look at the message.
Cernovich is a bad guy persona non grata and there's a number of things to
address.
One is a,
I used to troll pretty hard.
Twitter.
It's easy to say Twitter was a different place,
right?
That's,
this is like namaste.
A Twitter was a different place.
If you're James Gunn,
you get to say that if you're James Gunn or a lefty,
you get to just say,
you know what?
Twitter was different.
I was joking.
How dare you weaponize tweets and bad faith because we all know where that
happens.
For some reason,
the lefties are able to get away with past a agregious.
Things were bad jokes or whatever it is.
Where if you sort of step out of that,
you're not allowed to get away.
Yeah.
There's nothing worse than James Gunn.
Yeah,
but,
and this is,
and you say trolling just for the people that really aren't paying attention to
the Twitter nonsense or the youtube comment section,
just the average person that checks in on these conversations.
What do you mean by that?
Like,
so there's multiple layers.
There's a trolling merely to provoke and then for the,
for his own provocation,
and that was always sort of nasty.
I never did that stuff.
There was something,
for example called rip trolling,
which is trolls would go to a memorial site of someone's dead person and like
laugh about it,
which is just a moral evil.
And then there's using tactics that generate attention,
massive controversy,
but in a way that amplifies and underlying message.
That's why when people call Trump patrol is the Ursa he's using.
He's using a tactic.
So what I would do is I would use a certain tactic.
There's a,
there's a meanness to it really that everybody's a troll now though,
which is ironic because when you watch mad cow that she is a troll.
She's not a nice person.
She's on having open into conversations with people,
everybody now trolls.
So I was a troll kind of and then the left all became a troll and Trump won.
Then I become nice and now everybody is making people angrier and I realized
that just being a nice person is mixed people so angry.
That's why I wanted to have you on,
because I had seen an interesting evolution and you've been on sort of the side
of the hate machine and then you've been on the side of,
of taking the hate and all of those things.
So I thought,
all right,
why don't we start with this?
Uh,
right before I had you on,
I tweeted this out and I got a,
you know,
a series of people saying that,
um,
all right,
and you're a racist and all the usual stuff.
And these are verified journalists,
you know,
blue check,
verify journalists and all that.
But somebody,
it doesn't know,
we don't have to mention his name,
but a blue check guy said that your,
uh,
that Reuben is having a serial rapist on the show.
Now that's a,
that's a pretty serious accusation.
Yeah.
They make these massive accusations in.
The answer is they attack attack,
attack in any way.
And of course it's so weird accusations and I,
but no,
I'm not,
this is a lie.
The person saying,
have you ever raped any,
no.
Not only have I never not done anything like that,
but the people who make those allegations have made fake videos than me.
Fake videos.
And my daughter,
uh,
threatened to release revenge porn of me.
They claim they have a sex tape of me and they're going to release revenge porn,
which is actually a sex crime in California.
So the answer to that is no.
Now the question is why do people say that?
And why don't you just sue everybody?
And the answer is,
if you're me and you've been so smeared in the media,
you can't just go sue for defamation.
Because the theory is,
well,
nobody would believe it because they're saying it on Twitter.
But even if they would believe it,
then they wouldn't side with you because of whatever the reputation.
So they say either rapist,
rape,
apologist,
why supremacist and a men's rights activist.
So there's,
there's like a whole,
a whole slew of them.
And it's all very bizarre to me,
especially because I don't do any of that stuff,
don't want to do anything like that.
It'll have a very conventional life.
I have a wife,
two kids,
we hang out very kinda chill.
So your wife is Latina and by the way,
if the Persian,
Persian,
I thought she was Latina and she's Persian.
I'm also on Islamophobia even though even though half the people that are
wedding are Muslim,
you know,
so that's the,
so if you're,
so there's like three layers to this.
There is the layer of view,
the layer of my wife and then my layer,
your layers.
You're trying to kind of figure it out.
My wife's layer is,
she's like mortified.
How can they say this about you?
And then there's my layer where I'm just so used to false hoods and outright
lies that I don't even notice them anymore.
People are like,
oh,
so and so said that about you.
So you did have rape charges brought was falsely accused of rape in college.
This was in 2001 about the time period of the case took around five years.
Litigate charges were dismissed.
My record was expunged.
The only reason anybody knows about that is because I've spoken about it.
I love how they're like,
oh,
did you,
did you know about this?
Yes,
because I talked about it because I wrote about it.
No criminal record license attorney ever.
Literally there.
This is what expungement means.
Expungement means it did not exist as a matter of law.
So I could've just said never happened.
Never happened.
I've always spoken about openly though,
because that's one reason I'm passionate about due process.
That's one reason I'm passionate about these issues.
So there's all these gotcha things that people think they haven't.
I'm like,
no,
no.
You know that because I,
because I said it,
I never even had to say it,
but I believe in living in open and transparent life about it.
Now have I done some bad satire and,
and things that,
absolutely.
So that tweet for example,
can you explain that Dave?
Sure.
So,
so,
well,
the irony is the date rape tweet was an homage to Susan ash rich who wrote a
book called real rape.
And the thesis of the book is that all rape is rape is either rape or not rape.
And if you create this category of Eh,
is it or isn't it mean to develop fire?
Yeah,
see the rate for it's not,
you don't like if I murdered right here,
I wouldn't say I was,
you know,
Ruben murdered or acquaintance murdered.
You would just said,
well,
you were just murdered and the so when they call and I go,
no,
actually that's,
that's it.
Susan Nash thing.
This is a,
a second wave feminist argument,
which is you need to treat.
This is the problem with societies.
You need to treat it very seriously.
Like if we were walking outside and we saw somebody raped,
we would like take a baseball bat to the guy said nobody would be like,
oh,
rape apology,
you Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
You just,
you've just,
everybody knows what they would do.
But that said there,
now it's become a world where everybody's just tosses it around.
Oh,
that was ray.
If that was raped,
well this thing happened that was rape.
There's now even a thing that regret is rape.
Because if you feel bad the next day,
then you must not have had affirmative consent the night before.
So this is where,
this is where it's actually going.
Now my mistake is,
well,
number number of things.
One is when you have 40 Twitter followers and everybody knows that you're
talking about a specific article,
then people are like,
oh yeah,
they get it.
And then you become like famous or whatever.
And then people pretend that there wasn't that context to it.
But again,
this only happens if you're conservative.
A tree on the right.
If you're on the left,
you can say,
I'm James Gunn and he touches children.
Oh,
lol.
And Cernovich found these tweets.
How dare he's weaponizing bad faith.
So the answer to that is,
uh,
those tweets,
they're just not very smart.
They haven't actually read the literature.
They should go read since Nash Rich.
Now that said,
uh,
and I've learned this,
there's a lot of people been through some shit,
man.
Like I fat,
shame people feel bad about that.
Um,
I watched this video by Boogie and he talked about what fat shaming did to him.
So I'm like,
I fashion people as real shitty.
There are people reading me private and rate,
you know,
it's not something to be Glib about.
It's not something to joke about.
How much of that do you think?
And we've all been guilty of this,
so I do not sit here as holier than now.
Have I engaged in some of this type of stuff?
Sure.
Um,
I'd really try not to.
And then sometimes just the nature of the evil nature of Twitter just drags you
into it one way or another.
How much of what you were doing though was calculated just just so that you
could get followers so that you could get whatever your message is out there.
Well,
that stuff wasn't,
um,
that was just 40 people.
Everybody knows you're providing Meta commentary about an article that said,
you can judge me.
There are people who can judge me.
You can judge me.
Maybe Sam Harris can.
So you've got after Sam a couple of times.
Pretty hard.
Yeah.
But,
but so,
okay,
Sam,
I've gone after hard,
but not in fairly,
which is a difference.
Um,
because he,
he has this very,
uh,
dismissive article or attitude towards Trump's supporters.
And he was wrong about it.
But I don't go after Sam.
I'm nice to say I'm,
I'm nice to Ben.
There's enough people going after these guys,
I guess is the way I look at it.
I try not to go after anybody really.
I don't even want to tag people into tweets,
but you,
you could judge me.
Um,
I think you've had Harmeet on here.
She's like a Republican.
We have good judgment.
She can judge me if she,
you know,
she,
there's a few people who can,
but the idea that these people at buzzfeed who say,
kill all white men,
let's kill white people.
Have you killed a white person?
No,
no,
no.
They can't judge me.
So what frustrates them as,
I won't apologize for them ever for anything.
They can't.
There are a few people who can judge me.
They're certainly not on the crown though.
So,
so what do we do?
Regardless of what your
past is,
what do we do about this set of people that is this blue check set of Buzzfeed,
vox people that we know we're watching this right now waiting for you to screw
up one word or meet a pause in a weird way or get a glimmer in my eye,
like just any crazy things so they can selectively edited so they can just try
it as raise and they're,
what people need to understand is there's a business behind this and you're also
acknowledging that some of your business partook in some of these things.
Well,
I didn't do it for business.
I did to help Trump win.
So when I was trolling people like Sam and others,
the,
so the idea behind like salmon sandwich,
you're watching,
um,
I'm,
I'm apologize.
Uh,
but that sincere,
that's the globe.
See,
this is one thing I was thinking about today when we drive is we live in kind of
like the Glib Age,
which is,
oh,
so sorry.
It's like,
no,
no.
Like you're here.
If you're an asshole to person.
Sam had the credibility,
you apologize to someone for something a guest sat in when Sam said that I
thought,
son of a bitch,
you know,
so I publicly apologized.
I said,
you know what,
this you did the right thing,
so I'll do the right thing.
But when you're,
I think that
Chili is,
when I read this is probably about six or eight months ago,
and that's when I finally had reached out to you after about two years of not
speaking because I thought,
here's someone you're trying to acknowledge some of these things,
uh,
some of your past behavior.
And I thought,
we knew we want to destroy everybody.
We don't want it to give anyone a chance to come back from the brink.
And that I thought that was
commendable.
Well,
and that's what's interesting is they,
and this is the,
the reason that they're all freaking out is there are no longer,
they've lost gatekeeper status.
And this is,
this was talked about in the one I did with you two and a half years ago.
And now their methodology has changed where they go now to the tech companies in
Christ.
So,
so for example,
they're crying.
There's this girl,
so she's 14 she's got the,
they're gone,
you know,
so used to me,
they'd write a hit piece of Malaga,
Youtube.
How do you allow us person on there?
So here's my answer at all the blue checks.
I know they're watching all of you.
I'm putting,
I'm talking all of you right now.
You all know what Vic Berger did.
You know we had to do fake videos about my wife and daughter.
Fact,
you know that he's edited multiple videos about my daughter fat.
You know the emails she sent me,
the threats,
you know that I've gone to police.
You've seen the police reports.
So Paul about this is like some clown verifying climbs were there watching.
He calls me.
All right.
And Yeah,
this is my message to that he made fake videos about my wife and daughter.
There is a thousand fake videos of me where if I come on here and I said,
you know Dave,
they called me a murderer.
Yes,
I like to murder.
I know that'll end up in a soundboard and five years from now,
some boomers can be like,
oh wow,
I heard this audio where you said you'd like to murder people.
You know,
I don't care.
That's the game.
But going out to someone's wife and daughter beyond the Pale,
they all know about it.
Cause I emailed them and everything.
They won't write about it.
But then the go Dave Rubin,
this and that,
so they can show some integrity and they're all watching you write about that.
Say,
Hey Cernovich's of asshole.
He's a jerk.
He's a troll.
He's a bad guy.
You should never,
never make a fake video about an 18 month old girl.
My daughter was a time,
you should never make a fake video about a wife tag in child protective
services.
Never.
But they can't.
So they'll say,
demonically go,
Dave Rubin gives Cernovich's redemption article.
Reuben lets them come in and apologize,
but he didn't bring up these other 15 things and we'll just pretend that Vic
Berger hasn't tried to make his Cernovich's wiffle living hell right.
So screw all these people.
Well that's,
that's the thing is that the game,
no matter how many of these things I read off to you and no matter what mia
culpa you do or don't do that they never stopped.
I mean,
if I've learned anything in the last couple of years,
it's that they never stopped.
They just ratchet up every time.
But we,
let's,
let's back up to this 14 year old girl for a second.
Cause I don't know,
a lot of people knows what,
what's her name again or what's the Youtube Channel?
Not even sure.
Actually I,
her name was,
I saw for Sophie,
something like that.
So I saw this video.
It's a 14 year old girl and she does a really interesting biting,
sort of red pilling social commentary video.
This guy from buzzfeed decides to go after her and her channel is now banned or
suspended is,
I don't know if it's Spanish.
So she's one shackle that,
yeah.
Um,
so you've got buzzfeed going after kids,
literally for kids,
for satire.
The video was taken down.
It had something like 800,000 views.
But the guy who went after her,
who of course has gone after me before the rest of it.
And this is a buzzfeed verified guy.
Um,
he has a tweet,
I think you just referenced it saying,
kill all white people on your way to work today or something to that effect.
I mean,
now I have no doubt that he's joking,
right?
But it's like,
what rules are you guys playing by him?
Why is it that some people get protection and lauded for these things and some
people get destroyed by them?
And I'm glad you bring up this reporter and I won't name them because then
you're inciting harassment.
They'll go,
no,
they're inciting and he's nobody.
He's irrelevant other than he's trying to gain relevance by Baidu playing in a
really bad game,
I think.
Yeah.
But I'll tell you,
revealing story.
Uh,
I held an event in New York night for freedom 2008 teen and a number of bus
people.
People were there,
Chelsea manning was there.
So it became a story.
How dare Chelsea,
Mandy come to my story.
Even though everyone has nice to her and [inaudible] 30 year old white male was
arrested for almost beating a Jewish man to death.
He was walking home.
No,
no mainstream coverage of that.
They came to the event,
the same people who go,
oh yeah,
you're Dave Rubin is a gateway to radicalization,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
okay,
why?
Why don't they report it in Tiva?
Right?
Here's my,
here's this is,
I think that this is why they're losing trust.
If I read an article,
it says Cernovich is a piece of shit,
but so as Vic Berger and you should never go after kids and Antifa violence is
wrong,
I'd be like,
wow,
okay.
You know,
what are you gonna do?
Well,
we're all flawed,
but when I read these articles Cernovich Dis,
oh,
but by the way,
Cernovich when after James Gunn,
this was,
this was I think revealing.
My wife found this quite amusing as she goes,
Babe,
all these articles saying that you found James guns tweets and they're saying
he's choking and then they're saying,
but look at Cernovich's tweets.
But our tweets jokes are they sat tire or they need to be taken literally.
And the answer is there is no rule in anybody with a brain knows that the left
doesn't care.
They don't,
they're not nice.
They're not nice to people.
They don't call out their own side.
There's Chris Cuomo praises and Tifo.
We like Antifa Antifa beat up three marines in Philadelphia,
no media coverage.
The Guy who ran the smash racism,
d c Twitter Account Antifa do you see is being charged with hey crimes because
he called the Hispanic Marine,
uh,
w e t Bac k is facing.
Hey,
where's the coverage of that buzzfeed?
Where are you guys talking about how bright,
nowhere.
The shooter last week in Colorado,
I believe was a trans guy who was anti Trump supporter,
right?
Somehow that story went away.
Really goes right.
Real quick.
Skull,
the scalies shooting,
nobody says,
oh,
you know,
w who is radicalizing the far left.
They just,
let's pretend it didn't happen and we'll put,
we'll pretend that you're radicalizing people though,
even though the irony of this is that if anything,
you've D radicalized people because you've made people,
you and a few other people,
and this is why they hate the IDW or whatever it's called because you showing
people,
look,
you don't have to,
you're not calling this hug Elian thing where you're either a far left,
median accurate,
just the far right calling people Cox all day on Twitter or whatever hey is,
you know,
there's a little bit of room in between here.
Well,
that's the thing that I've realized is so bizarre.
All I think I've actually,
you look,
I've,
I've talked about the difference between leftism in liberalism.
Sure.
But I think what I did that they really hate is that I've shown that you can be
conservative or lean a little.
Right.
And that doesn't mean you're a bigot.
And that's a huge,
no,
no for these guys.
So do you think,
do you think that your tactics are just,
we're,
let's say just a reaction to their tactics that if they had behaved,
if they behave differently or if the media hadn't been so awful leading up to
Trump that you would have behaved differently or,
or maybe not even been relevant?
Because then when I had been looking for a Trump supporter,
how would I have ever found you?
So great question.
Why it is Angela Nagel got in trouble because she wrote a book called kill the
normies and kill it.
This is like a very online kind of thing,
but the idea was people like me are essentially right wing social justice
warriors.
So the left would do call out culture.
Oh,
Dave Rubin made this joke in 2015 can you believe we've got to cancel them?
And then people like,
and then there are the traditional conservatives who were like,
oh gasp,
I can't believe it.
This is so unfair.
The double standards.
And then there are people like,
okay,
I'm going to go through your tweets.
Let's find your,
let's play [inaudible].
This is how it's going to be.
Let's do this.
And then people like that leads to mutually assured destruction though.
So like when you were going after gun and you can explain it a little bit more,
like was like when I saw you doing it,
my feeling was these are obviously jokes,
they're all kind of gross.
We've all made bad jokes and this is the purpose of jokes,
right?
You want to get as close to that line as possible,
but sometimes when you're doing it,
you're going to trip over that line.
Um,
but did you have any sense of like,
if I keep ramping this up,
they will keep ramping this up and then what does that actually lead to?
Will gun is an,
is an unusual case because I have reason to believe that some of his stuff is
pretty bad.
The worst one was Bieber when he was 16.
I don't want to get in the weeds of that,
but people can read the tweets.
But there,
there is a sense of,
and we see this now with Rashida to lab and um,
um,
congresswoman Omar and them as the,
the left can't withstand the scrutiny that you and I take for granted.
We sit down,
we already know right away,
okay shit storm.
They're going to go after Dave.
Here's what they're going to say.
They're going to clip this or in a clip that we already know this.
You take it for granted,
you take it for granted.
But the,
these people on the left to go up and say Israel is hypnotized the world.
And like nothing happens.
The issue with James Gunn,
I always says,
why didn't he delete his tweets?
You know why he didn't have to?
Because nobody on the left was ever going to find his tweets.
Or if they did,
they weren't gonna do anything with them.
So Do you think Rosanna
bar then is the best example of the double?
Exactly.
No one in their right mind thinks that Roseanne Barr's are racist.
Her show was anti racist.
It was cutting edge.
It made working class people look decent,
white working class people,
which people now mock relentlessly.
Um,
and,
and I know her,
I mean this woman is not,
she had the first gay kiss ever on television was her,
I mean the idea that she's a racist or homophobic xenophobe or any of these
things,
but she had one bad tweet and I do believe her,
by the way,
that she didn't know she was pregnant.
I didn't even know she was.
I do believe that.
But regardless,
you could say it was one really stupid tweet and she's had many other stupid
tweets.
But the point is she lost the number one sit.
Come on television.
This is just last year.
Hold that from syndication.
Yeah,
it wasn't,
yeah.
Yeah.
So if you want to talk about overreaction,
the Dukes of Hazzard was pulled out a syndication because the generally had a
rebel flag on it,
which they weren't backing.
I mean,
the purpose of those were the good guys.
Yeah.
And right,
so they,
the overreaction.
So Roseanne and her show gets,
she gets fired,
pulled from syndication.
But then if a made man of the left says stuff way worse.
[inaudible] they attack the messenger,
they go after me.
My favorite article was,
and,
and this,
this kills them.
There's um,
there's a guy at CNN and his job is to dig up old tweets,
the people and he digs up old tweets.
He gets a lot of people fired and whatever.
That's the game now.
He was gonna fall special place in hell.
He was,
he was profiled in the Washington Post.
Great Guy.
He's the guy,
he'll never let you forget your past.
But then when the James Gunn thing happened in Washington Post said,
oh,
Cernovich is used a bad faith actor.
I like,
well,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
I mean our old tweets off limits or aren't,
are old comments off of them and said,
our tweets literal or they jokes,
are there satire or there or is there even redemption?
And the,
the issue that they have with me,
the left does is I will never apologize to them.
There's one tweet I will apologize for.
I would apologize.
I made a Glib remark about Trayvon Martin being shot.
I would apologize to his mom,
but if you're going to be,
if I and I and I sincerely would actually,
I mean you lose a child and,
and joking about it,
you know,
that's an issue that I've had to work on.
But this vicarious outrage,
I'm offended on behalf of all these people.
No,
I'm not going to apologize.
These people I'm going to and I'm going to just going to keep finding more stuff
that they said.
And now again,
I'm like Rashida till APP.
I'll make the devil's advocate case for her and then I'll make the the case for
her.
I can do both.
Right?
The devil's advocate case against her as she used holocausts and comic feeling
in the same line.
This is bad.
The case for her is that she was saying,
you know what,
I know my ancestors died so that Jews can move to Palestine.
And that makes me feel pretty good about myself.
Now this a historical component,
is that true?
No.
No,
but I can,
but again,
you know,
I'm a lawyer.
I can flip it,
right?
I can do both sides and yeah,
it's a historical and there there's recently doubted.
But if you are conservative,
that's,
they'd call everybody to disavow Pelosi's defending her.
So,
so that's the part,
I mean,
we're all over the place here,
but that's the part,
I mean,
I even tweeted that,
I think it was this morning or maybe yesterday,
it's like she lied about what the nature of 1948 war was.
And all of those things use the holidays in the worst sort of sense and are all,
I didn't,
it's not about piling on hurts.
Where is any decent Democrat ever.
The right always has to,
uh,
has to get rid of these guys and that's,
that's good.
Self policing is good,
but it seems that the left never has to do it.
And,
and that then I have this weird sympathy when people like you sometimes step
over a line.
I'm like,
well,
it's the only way to ever get anything done.
It may not be my tactic.
And,
and I sort of saw this with Milo years ago.
It was like I can understand his over the top ridiculousness because he's sort
of blowing things up so that maybe someone a little calmer like me could come in
and try to rebuild things.
And it's just,
it's just we all operate in different tactics.
Well,
yeah,
and the issue is a lot of people like I've evolved,
they know the Pizza Gate Post Pizza,
gay guy,
so I want to talk about this.
That's why they keep bringing up pizza gate,
right?
Because what have I done lately?
There was actually a really funny video for media matters where they go the,
the gist of it was Cernovich is being nice but don't let,
don't forget all these bad things he said.
But then a couple of the clips,
and this shows how people,
things get chopped up.
I did one video where I said,
you know what,
there's all this,
because I was part of the man's Internet,
whatever people call it,
the manosphere,
whatever it was.
And I,
I broke from that a long time ago,
but there was a racial element came in and I was like,
look,
you know,
I won't have any tolerance since racial element.
And I was like,
here's what people are saying about black guys on Twitter.
And then I repeated what I said and then that gets chopped up into a video.
Oh Cernovich you drop it in bombs.
No I wasn't calling anyone.
I was saying,
Hey,
you know,
I'm not having any tolerance for this kind of stuff.
Cause like our guys already have enough drama.
Yeah,
they did this all the time.
I mean literally an hour ago,
some blue check I was going after me because years ago on a livestream I years
ago when the old was just coming to fruition,
whatever that is.
I said as a me making joke machine,
there's something funny going on here,
but the previous sentence,
no,
the racists are bad,
the bigots are bad.
All of those things.
So what are they?
Of course daily beast didn't run that piece.
And then this guy is quoting,
it's like every freaking time and that's what they do.
And so the pizzagate thing is interest in for a number reasons.
One is that just do one oh one do pizza,
gay.
How the hell did this thing on the radar?
I actually did not track it that much.
I remember thinking at the time,
I was like,
I only have a certain bandwidth for enough Twitter craziness and I just kind of
let that one be.
I got bullied into talking about it.
So there were,
there was a,
a Podesta emails that wikileaks and there was a bunch of emails that don't even
make sense.
So there was one for example that said,
you left a handkerchief at your house.
There was a map on it,
something pizza related.
Now I don't who,
who would leave a Napkin at your house and somebody is going to email you.
You left a Napkin at my house,
you want me to mail it to you?
And so it was a little weird,
you know,
could have meant nothing,
could have been vague,
but then people thought,
oh,
that must mean pedestrians involved in something.
But I never said anything about John Pedesta.
Right.
I just said,
well,
yeah,
I mean there's all this stuff happening.
There's all these attempts to normalize pedophilia.
You can find articles in salon where they said pedophilia is a disorder,
not a crime.
There was an article,
and I'm not going to quote it because it would say it,
but the person wrote,
he's a pedophile,
not a monster that was in salon.
So I was like,
look dude,
there's all these efforts to normalize pedophilia.
I talked about the Jimmy's developing out of what the BBC,
I talked about Jeff Epstein,
I talked about all these great deals people are getting,
and then I used the Hashtag pizza gate.
So that becomes Cernovich said comet pizza.
And I said,
I never said comet pizza did anything.
So what they did,
you actually started the Hashtag?
No,
no,
no.
The hats or no,
no,
no.
The hashtag was already started way before me and I just thought,
oh,
this is a hash either talking about pedophilia and you know,
Jeffrey Epstein and whatnot,
which by the way,
I'm in precedent setting litigation about freedom of the press involving Jeffrey
Epstein,
Miami Herald reported on it.
They're in the same case as me.
So Cernovich she's in a case with the Miami Herald seeking records about Jeff
Epstein.
So what they did was they,
they,
if they're honest,
here's what they said,
and this is true.
They'll say,
you know,
you amplified a Hashtag and he should've been more careful and you should have
paid attention.
And the answer that is,
yeah.
Should have.
You're right.
That was for me like,
oh,
okay,
we gotta,
we gotta be a little more careful.
But the flip side is,
I never said anything about comet pizza.
And in fact,
this same guy who made fake videos and my wife made a video where I say comet
pizza,
but only because I was talking about James O'keefe video where blah,
blah,
blah.
We're going way into the weeds.
But it's important to lay out some of this because the,
because part of,
I think what's happening here is the inability for mainstream,
whatever that is,
the increasing layer of mainstream that's just shedding relentlessly by their
own doing.
It's their inability to deal with any of the outsiders.
So,
I mean it's the way they respond to things that I do.
It's like they can't understand that people might have a different take on
internet culture or on just outsider culture or any of the trolling Romy making.
They just can't piece it all together.
Well,
they can't piece it all together there.
They don't want to do nuance.
So there's a number of pressures.
And I went into this with hoax hoax that my movies started off with.
I was,
I become much less conspiratorial.
The more I've learned about these people.
And the biggest problem in media,
well not the biggest,
but one of the big problems is cable news.
It's the same 10 people,
oh,
today we're gonna talk about Saudi Arabia and Qatar.
Tomorrow we're going to talk about banking and tariffs on China.
Are you out of your mind?
How can some 28 year old with a BA in anything know that?
Why don't you bring actual experts on?
And they all talk about everything.
So then when they go pizza gate,
they're like,
hey,
Google it.
Give me the five minute summary.
Oh,
pizza gate.
Cernovich sorry,
repeat the gate.
Dah,
the end.
And they don't ever get in the weeds of any kind of surgery for no expertise.
So then you,
so for,
so for example,
oh,
tariffs are are bad now apparently they're saying Trump was gonna win,
the market was gonna crash.
I was like,
well no,
the market is at record highs and they so they,
they all,
rather than having actual experts on to discuss the issues,
then they just talk like they're experts on everything.
It's amazing to think about.
Right?
Yeah.
Well everyone on Twitter is an expert about anything.
Well,
I try to,
if you don't declare centrifuges,
I don't,
but,
but you don't try to do that.
I don't try to do that.
Like if you asked me something out of my comfort zone,
I would say,
well I kind of have a take on that,
but not really.
And when I came on,
and this is them,
this is kind of segways into you having experts on your show.
I'm an expert on Trump,
meme,
culture,
persuasion,
the Internet,
you name,
but I'm an expert on it in terms of mass human psychology trends where things
are going.
So then you go,
well,
I mean I can't know everything.
I'll have this guy on here.
Oh,
he's got baggage.
And that baggage becomes your baggage.
Yeah.
When did
just such intellectual hostage taking,
I mean that's the thing.
So wait,
let's,
let's really dive into something here.
So about a year ago,
I think it was a year ago,
last week was when that big renegades of the intellectual dark web,
a piece came out in the New York Times.
And the piece,
Barry Weiss wrote the piece.
And I know Barry gets a ton of hate online and I've,
I've sort of mixed feelings about her,
but whatever it is,
um,
in the piece she sort of threw me and rogue and under the bus because she said,
if you talk to people like Mike Cernovich and Alex Jones,
now sir,
uh,
Jones had been on Rogan show a bunch of times and he's been on since,
and here you are.
And you had been on my show that you're either stupid or cynical.
Um,
now I didn't like the line because to me it's like Joe and I are our
interviewers,
at least when we're doing our shows.
And it's like you're going to have to talk to people outside of your box.
I'm not even,
I'm not even referencing you here.
You talk to all sorts of people.
That's what an interviewer does.
Right?
Um,
but she said you'd have to be stupid or cynical to talk to those people.
And I was wondering,
uh,
you're,
you're a source for all sorts of people.
I'm guessing probably the New York Times and all sorts of different papers and
all sorts of things.
Now we happen to be doing this publicly,
so all the haters can watch in.
Anyone can judge whatever they want about anything we say.
Um,
but I suspect you probably talked to all sorts of reporters and all sorts of
things and it just goes under the radar and that's why it's acceptable for those
people.
Am I completely off base here?
Cernovich
well,
sometimes I feel like Rodney Dangerfield,
no respect.
I can't get no respect.
Right.
It's like hit me for the things I said and done that are wrong pit before him,
but she can't deny.
I made a member of Congress,
John Conyers design through my reporting,
which I handed off to to meet the Alice Ivan handed.
All were not happy about that.
No speed had to credit you for that.
Yeah,
they had to and I've handed off all kinds of stories to people in all kinds of
publications and I'm not gonna out him,
but we'll just say the prestigious publications in the country have run stories
where I sourced it or I hand deliver them something because me,
I just,
I took a pivot and I wanted to move under the radar a little bit.
So I'm not asking you,
obviously the boys source or a,
or you are the source,
but to blow a connection other than to say,
I think it's just worth noting because that line sort of stuck out of that
article and it's like,
well you guys just do it on the DL,
you're all doing it on the DL and then you think you're holier than thou and,
and uh,
well that it's personal to me.
So,
well it is,
and not only that,
but the question I always have for people like her is,
and again,
she gets a lot of hate and everything else.
I don't wanna I don't wanna I don't want to pile on her.
She gets,
she gets a ton of come to that position of love.
If I were already completely cynical and jaded,
I would say,
well,
you know,
Ms. Wise,
um,
I've,
I made a member of Congress is on how many reporters and their entire career can
say I uncovered a secret sexual harassment settlement involving a very powerful
mumbler congress.
My reporting led to him resigning.
How many people can say that?
How many people can say they wrote a book on mindset too.
Um,
we're at 100,000 copies,
over a hundred thousand copies sold.
Most books don't even sell it.
How many people can say that?
How many people can say,
I broke the Susan Rice unmasking story,
massive stories.
Hr,
McMaster,
the,
at the time,
national security advisor,
United States of America held meetings about me because he was feared.
He was obsessed with me.
Foreign policy even called me the object of his obsession say,
hate me or love me.
How many people can say in a career that they've done,
even one of these things that I've done.
So who is serious and who isn't?
Right.
Do you think part of everything we've talked about so far is just that as you
mature in a career,
one way or another,
that tactics change when you become,
hopefully you become a better person.
Um,
obviously with me,
even things like,
you know,
there was like Spurg out.
I'd be like,
oh,
this person is burning out.
I had a couple of miles back,
hey,
you know,
my son has autism.
And I was like,
yeah,
I just felt kind of bad about it.
Actually don't even know what that means.
Okay.
Well it's,
um,
when people get a little angry and jittery and maybe throw a temper tantrum or
whatever and it's a,
it's like,
you know,
it was,
yeah,
I didn't even know it was,
I was like,
okay,
so I don't say the r word ret rd.
I don't say that anymore.
I just,
well,
I don't know.
People read me and their kids are having developmental problems.
Why would I make them feel shitty?
You know,
why?
Why would I make them feel like they want to just come here?
Why would I just make them feel shitty?
And that's the irony of the arguments to know platform people is you become
normalized as you become more whatever famous because you get more inputs now.
It isn't just you and 50 people knuckleheads seeing who can be the most
offensive and you're like,
wow,
why do I want to fashion?
And people,
I,
you know,
there's probably somebody fat reading me right now and maybe I should try to try
to think of a way to,
to lift their mood and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And then of course,
you know,
things that I didn't take seriously before.
I know realize real prompt people would be like three years ago,
you know,
antisemitism,
prominent American.
I'm like,
well people call me an ass am I don't even talk about this stuff.
I don't even,
that's not even my lane,
you know,
if you want to call me massage and it's just like,
well there's a to be had,
but if you're calling me like an Islamophobia for an anti Semite,
it's like,
no,
we're just not even in the same ballpark here.
But then,
you know,
like I talked a lot of my Jewish readers and stuff,
I'm like,
yeah,
there is,
there is a problem.
And then there was a synagogue shooting.
So yeah,
clearly there's a problem,
but that's the idea is the more people you talk to you and the more you get out
of your own space and your own little niche to morning Rosa.
Okay.
It's my behavior really reflecting while and then as you become more prominent,
then you start to think,
well,
anything that I do is going to be used against people who have been nice to me.
So now I have,
so it's called the growing up.
Yeah,
well it's all just social
stupid because it's like I forgetting that the usual suspects will come after me
for even doing this.
It's like there's probably somebody out there now that I would like to get on
the show that simply will not come on the show because I'm doing this right now.
I mean,
even yesterday I,
uh,
I contacted uh,
Paul booty booty judge edge food.
Yeah.
Uh,
his PR person DMD me cause I asked him to come on the show and we're looking
into it.
But then the,
the blue checkers.
Yeah,
yeah.
You call,
you know,
calling me all these awful things and it's like,
what are you guys all doing?
Like what,
what is it that they're all trying to accomplish by,
by d platforming and destroying everybody?
Well,
it's turf forests there.
Something interesting happened when having a post had to lay off a bunch of
people like,
oh,
everyone's like,
oh my God,
hire these great minds or whatever,
and I went to their Twitter cause I'm like,
nope,
no you're not.
You're not interesting.
You're not.
This is another basic hot take,
white male patriarchy due to everybody's evils.
Like no,
they're fungible.
What they're doing is they're producing a functional content,
which is outrage directed a specific group of people and then people like you,
people like Joe Rogan,
they're jealous.
There's also those people and they rather than just say,
and again this is like a mindset issue rather than Tressa.
Yeah,
I'm kind of jealous.
Those people,
maybe autumn,
I figured out what they're doing maybe ought to up my own game.
They want to attack and destroy and largely that's because leftwing politics
today,
orthodoxy is largely based on the edge resentment.
How do you think or why do you do,
I think Trump got this,
like if we were going back three and a half years ago to that first sit down,
I'm sure I asked you something to that effect that the very nascent version
of it,
but what do you think about Trump?
Is it that,
that he understands this thing?
He's a leftist?
Um,
he,
yes,
he was always a liberal before I became a Republican.
I was all the,
if you reform leftists are the of the left worst nightmare.
Because psychologically,
and I don't know,
this is something I haven't heard a good answer for.
Jordan Pearson Cottey touches on it.
There's a difference between a left wing brain and right brain,
the conservatives,
the American Eagles,
that sort of campy stuff.
And I don't want to be dismissive,
but that's just not me,
right?
I'm,
I would rather look at Jackson Pollock or something.
I think that's the real art.
And Trump thinks like a leftist and he's thinking,
how can I get under their skin,
right?
I'm going to get,
I'm going to get under the skin.
How can I get another snake skin because he understood that that was what
brought you cultural relevance and cultural significance is getting under the
skin of the other side,
which has now become medically is called owning the libs.
So now you have all these people on the right,
oh lol.
Owning the libs is become a meaning of its own and now the left is saying all
these people want to own the libs.
But then actually they say that in a fairly,
sometimes there's a profile on Candice Owens who Charlie Kirk and they said all
they do is own the libs and that was dismissive and untrue.
But the medically there is a sense of it and we're going to rile them up.
And Trump is great at riling people up because his brain,
he has a leftist brain.
It's so interesting the two d arguments on a lot of this stuff,
cause you probably know,
I often go to colleges with Candace and Charlie and yes,
do they,
you know,
are their chance of build the wall and do they,
are they screaming and all of these things.
There's a lot of that.
But you know what they're mostly is,
I would say 90%.
It's actually talking about ideas.
And we'd go up there and we talk about the things that we disagree on,
but you can't get the media to report on that.
They will only report on it in the two D way.
And then what that does is the people that were there or that see video of it
go,
oh,
well you guys are just liars because that's not really what happened there.
There's some kids having some fun chanting,
right.
Damn will.
And that becomes,
so that becomes a crisis of confidence and that's why more and more people lose
trust in me.
I'll give you a great example.
That sincere is when I read a daily beast article where they said,
Jacob Wall put this kid up to making a false accusation against mayor Pete.
And we have tape.
I was like,
I think I said Paul before,
by the way,
it's p.
Dot.
[inaudible] P.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
and I thought that they might provide this line because they've lied about me
before.
So when I read an article now,
I don't think,
oh,
this is informing my peanut.
I'm like,
yeah,
this is the probably lying or that suck beyond imagination.
I mean,
if you care about truth in any way whatsoever,
and I don't mean you know,
like anyone watching this,
if you care about truth,
like during the Jesse smell,
that thing the entire time I was like,
this all just read so wrong.
But,
but it's not just that the media is lying about it to gin everybody up to,
to start a freaking race war.
It's that the politicians that are all tweeting that this is an example of white
supremacy in America and coming to end gate 15 year old kids,
you want to talk about bullying,
Cernovich,
bully,
blah blah blah.
And they went after 15 year old kid,
right?
Get out of hoax based on a hoax and then the writeup absolve themselves of all
personal responsibility is,
and our kids have got killed.
So is there a line that you draw then?
Cause the other part of the,
uh,
of the New York Times article,
why is New York Times article is basically that there needs to be just,
uh,
well she was in this case she was talking about the IDW whatever you,
however you want to define that.
But generally speaking,
do you have sort of boundaries of what gatekeeping should it be like what ideas
are so fringe that are so,
I mean,
people call you a white nationalists,
are you,
do you believe that America should be a white nationalist?
That's as,
I never have written about it.
That's what,
but that's bizarre about me is they with your Persian wife?
Yeah.
Well that's what I would say.
Like where does my Persian wife fit into this?
Right.
I don't even,
I don't even talk about this kind of stuff.
And when you look at actually immigrant populations,
the Indians tend to be more innovative.
There's the idea behind immigration.
We talked about this in 2015.
Over three feels like a deputy over three years ago.
I'm all for it.
I just,
I'm a,
I'm a believer in,
we have enough people here making 12 bucks an hour,
so we don't need anybody else here who can take $12 an hour jobs.
But if we can get people who are really brilliant from all over the world,
let's skim.
I'm a cream skimmer.
I want to bring the smartest people over and bring them all over here and make
America great place for them.
And they try to say,
oh,
I'm like,
well I live my reveal preferences are antithetical to the accusations they make.
Now that said,
are any ideas off limits?
And I've always held the belief that no idea is off limits.
You can talk about anything.
It's fundamentally how people treat you.
And there is an example of,
there are people for example,
that they wanted me to do their show and I want to do this show because I just
don't like them.
Like you're just a nasty person.
I don't know.
I don't want to talk to you about anything.
You're,
you're a bad person.
It isn't that they're too far left for me.
And then of course,
what I thought was funny to you is I always see people tweeting out that you
won't have a socialist on your show,
but they will come on your show.
Right?
I mean,
I'm sure some socialists word,
but I've had plenty of lefty.
I mean,
this argument is so boring.
It's like,
you know,
right.
It's just,
it's just never endingly ridiculous.
It's like if my lefties that I have on all the time aren't left enough for you,
it might be you.
That's the problem rather than,
than my guest choices.
Um,
yeah.
But there's any ideas.
I think people should be able to talk about any kind of ideas.
Fundamentally.
It's how do you,
how do you treat people?
And I think that we're seeing now is something that I predicted I might've,
I think I talked about on your show actually.
Uh,
if not,
I have to rewash clip.
But what happens when you put ideas off limits are there's nobody to be like,
hey,
that was a really dumb thing.
You said you're just with 50 other people in discord server trying to one up
each other and you're with the them and then you,
you get in a downward spiral and vast when you have violence,
they shut people down and then that's when people are starting to get violent
and we're actually,
we're seeing that backlash and that's why I wake up every day and I'm like,
oh,
of course the left got worse today.
Of course they got worse.
They,
of course,
they go to work today because I kept saying,
guys,
we can't call everybody racist.
We meaning me as a lefty too.
We can't call everybody racist.
You can't say that.
Everybody who wants stricter immigration then you want the type of thing that
Obama ran on or Bill Clinton used to talk about all the time.
You can't say that they're all racists because of that,
but every day there's just another version of that and it seems like they're,
it seems like there's just no adult in the room.
Well,
I thought Trump was blues for sure.
2020 thought for sure.
If you'd asked me a year ago,
I was like,
oh yeah,
Trump and the left decided that they didn't want to.
When you're talking about,
well the baby's born,
we'll make her comfortable.
I don't think the left.
So just to be clear,
I don't think the left wants to chop off the heads of babies,
but if you can't just say some concession there.
Yeah,
exactly.
But if you can't just say,
because you're so afraid of the mob.
No,
no,
no.
The baby's out of the womb.
Nobody's supports poster birth abortion.
You,
they can't even say that because they're terrified that the lot to also,
you're saying a woman doesn't have complete control.
They can't even draw any kind of lines where you're like,
look man,
we all know eight,
you know,
eight and a half months that the mothers healthy.
There aren't going be any kind of complicated.
And,
and the irony of that too is it's such a marginal issue to go to lose on.
It's like a hill.
You're dying on women who are pro choice don't want to kill her babies.
Now there's a prolife or saying,
well but life begins at conception.
That's a different debate.
But women who are eight and a half months pregnant are not trying to go to the
clinic,
but the,
the left is so afraid of freaking out their base of just feral monsters or
whatever that they won't even just say what I just said,
which is so not so.
They have to make everything sound like it's okay.
And then as I say all the time,
then it's like for me who's begrudgingly pro choice,
I mean I still am,
even though I've heard far more compelling prolife arguments than pro choice
arguments at this point,
it makes my position impossible to hold.
Cause I know I'm holding this temporary position on quicksand because I know
these guys are going off the deep end and that's why they're there creating no
backlash.
I talked to my,
um,
my wife and I,
we talk about if we're going to be Christians and go to church because you just
look around and so debased.
Now they're,
they're,
they're the big,
they're going to,
there's going to be a big revolution of Christianity or Islam or something where
people are just sick of the generous.
He like,
I'm,
I've,
I was always pro gay marriage before it was a thing,
cause I'm libertarian.
20 years ago in law school I was like,
dude,
do you know why can't adults enter into contracts it blah,
blah,
blah blah.
But 11 year old kids on stage with dollar bills throwing at them.
No,
sorry dude.
Right.
Sorry.
Record that has nothing to do with gay marriage.
No,
no,
no.
I get what you're wearing.
Libertarian.
If you want to be a drag queen,
a trends.
Yeah.
I don't care man.
It's your life is hard.
Whatever you do to help you get through it,
it's fine.
Well there's,
somebody tweeted this,
I wish I knew who it was,
but they were saying how this,
how the left was lauding this 11 year old drag queen and guys were throwing
bills at this kid.
They're saying that's amazing.
But now these 14 year old that we referenced earlier,
who's making edgy jokes on Youtube,
oh,
that's an old right,
racist.
And it's like,
pick one guys.
Which way are we going here?
Well,
and that's the problem.
The,
the left doesn't have a governing moral standard outside of victimization.
Who's the biggest victim and how can we need,
you talked about this and the inversion of values and their story that tranche
laws,
and this is all this is all been prophesied by him.
And so like sick,
except the 14 year old kid for example,
self,
you watch her and they're saying,
oh my God,
she's talking about killing gay people.
And then you watch a video.
No,
no,
no.
It's actually met a commentary,
right?
She's,
she's pointing out the hypocrisy of well,
if you criticize Islam,
you're Islamophobic.
Okay,
but you know,
gays maybe don't do so well,
maybe it's fair to ask that question.
No,
no,
you can't do that.
So she is doing it and her dead pan delivery style.
And when I watch I'm like,
wow,
she's more talented to me.
Now if somebody said,
where are the parents?
I'd be like,
well,
okay,
you know,
that that's the more their child actors and,
or is she being protected from groomers?
And,
but then if you tried to apply that same,
uh,
same standard to Desmond is amazing.
Now you're a bigot and you just,
you hate,
you hate everybody else gave people Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
So there,
there's no universal standard that you just apply and you apply evenly down the
board.
Do you think that will lead to a resurgence in religion?
And I think this has a little bit to do with sort of the Jordan Peterson
phenomenon over the last year.
He's not telling people to be religious and practice per se,
but he's explaining why the stories of religion have value.
And I do,
I see that,
I mean I traveled the world with the guy and I saw it happening in real time.
Yeah.
Jordan Peterson is a secular religion,
which may be,
seems contrary to,
but not really just the old school of virtues.
I think Aristotle is going to come back a Ryan holiday popularize that Stoics,
right?
So Ryan holiday has his own,
you know,
books on stoicism.
And the idea of dealing with the world,
trying to live virtuously trying to tr to be a good person and you're going to
see a return of virtue that will absolutely,
it's already making a comeback.
I'm less of a piece of shit sometimes because I look around and I'm like,
I don't want to,
like,
I've seen the mirror now.
Okay,
this is me,
these people that I don't like.
That was me three years ago.
I don't like that.
That isn't what I want to see.
So I'm in my own way,
living my own virtuous life,
which makes me,
can try it about some things while still having the sense of,
but I'm not gonna apologize to the people who are doing it.
It's quite all right.
So let's,
let's back up to the censorship stuff because obviously now,
so Alex Jones has been booted from youtube than last week or 10 days ago or so.
Uh,
Facebook and,
uh,
what else was it?
Instagram took him.
Paul,
Joseph Watson,
Laura Loomer,
a couple others.
Um,
first off,
do you see any meaningful distinction between any of these people?
How do you,
how do you pay apologists of Watson?
Right.
It just,
you could say guilt by association with Alex.
Paul's the most above board clean cut,
all hits above them.
He does.
Pretty sure if we now post this video on Facebook,
you've now said something nice about him and the page by page could probably
know.
That's actually true.
That that's,
that's funny.
The Stalinist stick on prayers.
I remember I wrote a book called the comments are vanishes.
Everyone should watch or read this book or at least pretend to override it,
you know,
to be a cultured person.
And they would show how pictures would be edited as Stalin would have people
killed.
These people would be added on pictures.
And I remember reading this 20 years ago,
I can't believe that ever happened.
And I'm not like,
no,
I can totally believe it happened.
And I see the parallels and they ban people for off platform content,
uh,
conduct.
But they won't be in the people who make fake videos.
And my wife and daughter for [inaudible] information and I don't,
I don't see how Milo's he's cleaned up his act if anything had become kind of
fish ticket,
you know,
anymore.
And,
but do you see any distinction between any of these people?
Like is there somebody that's done something that you think is so overboard?
No,
definitely not over the,
there's nothing,
um,
Alex Jones,
people forget to mention he's apologized for sandy hook so many times.
Repeatedly he went on Joe Rogan I didn't realize on my followers were not,
some were going to go harass these parents and I wish I'd have known that,
but it's like,
okay,
we're sorry bro.
Like what are we supposed to do?
And then,
and then they wipe them out.
So there was nothing any of them send that was over the top.
So what do we do then that forgetting the specifics?
I,
I happen to like Paul a lot and I think his videos are good and yeah,
I think he's funny and I think he gets some of the culture stuff that you're
talking about are not some of it.
I think he probably gets all of it.
Probably gets a lot of it in a way that I don't even get,
let's say.
Um,
but these all happened to be right leaning people.
Lot of a lot of lefties can get away with a Lotta stuff.
We've referenced some of it already.
Yeah.
Well anybody who doesn't think Facebook is the new Russia is missing the trend.
This is election interference and they're going after pro Trump influencers.
People who have cultural cachet,
people who can get votes for Trump and they're getting rid of them before it
becomes too hard,
too hot to handle.
Once we're full in primary season,
it'll be too on the nose.
His election in France.
So it's election our fence 100% that's why they're doing it.
They're banning influential pro Trump people there are silencing them and not by
any kind of rules like so here.
So here's an example.
The,
you know,
I'm not putting anybody on blast.
These are my friends and everything.
I'll just say that I've messaged people before.
Some people you named and some you haven't said,
I think this is,
you shouldn't say this.
I think this is kind of nasty now.
It's not a very nice thing.
Not It wasn't hate speech,
but there Facebook doesn't say,
Hey,
you know this is like a nasty thing.
Don't say this.
Right.
Don't refer to Muslims as animals for example.
This is like a pretty clear rule.
If you refer to Muslims is filthy.
Jihad is like,
okay bro,
you know,
come on,
but you can call it Jews.
Cockroaches.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
So there,
there is a double standard element and you can't like meet with them and they're
like,
okay,
here's the 10 things you did wrong.
You're going to come back in a probationary period.
No bullshit.
You better just be,
if you feel like you're close to the line,
don't even go near the line.
That's what you would do in a functioning working system that was actually
trying to make the world a better place and increase the value of the
conversation and not interfere,
manipulate the election.
You'll just say,
look,
this is,
this is a bad thing.
You said,
here's why this is the rule.
Don't say it.
There's,
there's none of that.
So do you think platforms just cannot exist as they have existed for the last
five or 10 years then that they've become too much?
Uh,
too much of a sort of informational behemoths.
There are two so many voices on there competing and then you've got a social
justice mentality out of silicon valley that it's all the inequities.
So when Tim Pool has to explain this right to Jack's face on Joe Rogan,
it all looks ridiculous because it is ridiculous.
Well,
they have monopolies and this is something that isn't mentioned enough.
There's a,
there's a guy,
there's like a new upstart rock fin that's trying to,
that explain this while there's something called Metcalf's law,
which is there's a formula where the value of the network increases
synergistically based on more people you have and what Youtube did,
and this is why I don't have any sympathy for the other private companies taking
over the one.
No,
they can't.
Here's why.
Joe Rogan built Youtube Pewdie Pie Bill Youtube.
They brought all the people who liked them onto youtube.
Youtube provided a platform.
Bullshit.
We all remember what Youtube said.
Come on up.
You can say anything,
bring all your people.
And then they built that network up.
And then once youtube had the network effect and networks,
Peter Teal talks about this in zero to one and his other writings,
networks tend towards monopolization.
So once they have a monopoly now in video,
which youtube has Facebook and Twitter,
they'll have their own respective monopolies.
Then they say,
oh,
you gotta go.
And then these free market can serve as well as private company that can do
anything want.
Nobody's in its fraud.
They lied to people to get people to put their time and the resources,
thousands hours and their channel to build that network under Metcalf's law.
And now they're,
they're changing the rules.
That is
civil part.
So let's,
so let's dive into this a little bit more because you've probably seen my tweets
on this and this is pushing my libertarian side to its end point.
I feel like that's what's happening right now is that,
I know right this second by having you on or for not even having you on for any
reason.
Could they pull the plug or right this second?
Would I be if I had to bet my life right now?
Have they depressed the views of this livestream?
Yes.
Are they my channels over a million subscribers?
We're getting 20,000 views on some things.
Are they fucking with us?
Yes.
His Twitter shadow banning.
Have they,
has it all gotten worse?
Oddly,
since I had James O'keefe?
Yes.
I mean we could do like a list of all of this shit.
Right?
So,
but putting that aside for a second,
my,
my core libertarian belief is that I would prefer that competition solve this.
Why do you think that that's not a,
a sound art?
Because they're natural monopolies is social media company,
a tech companies in natural monopoly,
uh,
power companies and natural monopolies,
standard oils and natural monopoly.
The railway tracks or natural monopoly.
So you have certain industries that tend towards monopolization and if you have
an,
you can't have a free market competition because the do the economy scales in
the Metcalf's law.
Now,
the counter to that,
if,
but this would be counterfactual is if five years ago youtube had said,
hey,
come onto our platform.
We might ban you just because we don't like you going to like what you're saying
or some middle managers and like you might be on you but come on up and put your
videos on here.
Well then you would have had somebody say,
oh no,
come on over here that you would have had a real competition.
So these social media,
they all know.
I mean this is zero to one.
These are natural monopolies.
This is been,
it was a a priori.
This is what people thought and it's been established a post Jerry that that
they're natural monopolies.
So there,
there is no free market.
So here's the odd part,
okay,
let's,
let's buy your argument for the,
just for the sake of this.
So let's say we completely buy that,
right?
Well now what I see happening is I see conservative saying,
where is Trump?
Where is Trump?
The government's got to come in and break it up or it's got a,
they've got to regulate these things or whatever.
Now,
I understand this might be a moment where you might want to do this,
especially if what you just laid out about 2020 is true.
You might want to do it right now,
but would you Mike Cernovich want a hand that power over to the government when
it's possible Trump
loses.
And then you've got silicon valley full of postmodern leftist,
and then you've got Bernie in the White House and then,
and then what do you have?
They'll do it anyway.
Obama or the IRS to investigate all these people and illegal audits done in a
John Mccain and Obama.
So to me,
the thinking is this tit for tat is so for running a game theory simulation.
Well,
if I do it,
they'll do it.
I'll do okay,
but they've already done it and they do it.
It's the same thing with tweets.
People go,
well,
don't you think by digging up tweets,
they might retaliate.
And I'm like,
oh.
So they might dig up my treats 10,000 times.
Oh my God.
And that's where we are.
The left.
They're going to do it anyway.
Now,
the irony of this conversation is if Hillary Clinton had won,
none of this would've happened because here's why.
She left these idiots over there,
bark in the corner.
They don't have any real power.
What they learned is there's real influence.
There's real power.
These people aren't just eat.
Remember East Aleppo,
this is the celebrity.
You don't hear that much anymore because people realize the idea is we actually
jumped.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Like when I walk around,
I remember when I was at the RNC,
there was MSNBC guy there,
I think Chris Hayes's name,
but more people recognize me than him.
Just from Easel Leb,
right?
Yeah,
and they,
they would have,
that would have been happy,
let these people scream and rant and rave while we actually govern,
and then they realized that no,
they do have real influence.
Now we have to do something about it.
And the,
the big trend now is they're getting rid of the big pro Trump influencers.
Now they're nudging.
There's a,
there's a great book that everybody should recall nudge.
And the idea is how can you as a government help people make better choices?
The prototypical example is organ donors.
If you just have people opt in,
it's a good thing.
Societal good donate organs.
We all agree.
If you ask people,
do you want to donate?
Most people say no.
If you just say,
do you want to opt out?
Most people said,
no,
I'll be one.
So that's a nudge.
You're not telling people what to do.
You just nudging them.
That's where the tech trend now is.
So if people Google Dave Rubin,
they're gonna find the hate pieces,
they're going to find the hate articles there and they're going to bury anything
about you and your channel.
And that's another way that the narrative has been manipulated in the native is
being influenced.
So,
so what would you want then?
Right now for Trump to do oh fourth or the government related to all the tech
hub?
Okay,
well it's too late now,
but if I had a magic wand then when Trump had a republican majority in both
houses,
they would have said,
you know what?
Why is it that if somebody liables me on Facebook,
I can't sue Facebook?
Facebook says,
well,
we're a platform,
not a publisher.
You can't.
So they have CDA section two 30 just abolish it.
No,
you want to be publishers now and you want to just to clarify this for people
that aren't fully on all this,
the idea of the platform versus publisher.
Okay.
So there's a provision of the millennial millennial digital copyright act
section or a CDA comedian Decency Act Section 230 and under this act it says
that no platform will be liable for third party content.
Example.
I'm sure there's,
right now Sony and Youtube calling me the,
the most awful things that I could still have for,
I can't say youtube for that.
I can go sue that anonymous bro for that under only because section two 30,
uh,
exists.
And the rationale behind that was,
I mean,
you can't expect somebody to,
you can't expect Facebook to please 2 billion people.
They're just providing a platform for people to share their minds.
But they're not a publisher like the New York Times or like you.
So you,
Dave,
Ruben,
your publisher,
if you say something bad,
okay,
we'll,
you're a publisher.
You're not a platform.
And Youtube is fine though.
So the ideas is what?
What?
No,
they're acting as they're acting as publishers now they're calling themselves
publishers because they are now deciding who can exactly.
Right.
Okay.
So you don't get this precious little mute anymore.
Now you would limit it.
So you know,
some guy with a blog or something,
right?
You would say anybody with revenues of over a billion dollars a year or
something like that shall be held liable.
And you eliminate that.
But then what's going to happen with tech companies and freak out,
right?
Well,
tough luck.
You're publishers now.
So you'd hold them to that too.
Is the FTC finding his Facebook make it 20 billion?
We all know,
we all know that we're,
you and I are here.
And I said,
Oh boy,
I sure am Craig.
You know,
playing a game of basketball.
And then we all know there's going to be an APP.
It's gonna appear for Spalding basketball.
We just know it.
We know they're spying on us.
We know this is illegal.
We know this is why our tap criminally prosecuted them and dine them and died
them under the five Federal Wiretap Act.
These are all laws on the books and by the way,
what they're doing,
and again,
this goes back to the glibness of our age where because everything's outrageous,
nothing is,
it truly is outrageous that even if you opt out of Facebook's spying program,
they still spy on you.
Even if you do everything right,
they can still spine.
This is human human spine,
like never up an item and item Federal Rico Kiss.
So in that Trump doesn't have congress now and did not.
Well,
he couldn't.
Doj could do that without him.
So Doj couldn't die.
Facebook for privacy violations.
The Federal Trade Commission could say 5 billion isn't enough.
You need to pay 20 billion,
100 billion.
There's nothing enough a,
a DOJ antitrust enforcement could go after,
could go after youtube.
So there's already enough laws on the books too,
which is why when people were like,
oh,
we need to,
there's already laws here.
We don't need a new law.
Where do you think Trump's thinking right now?
Oh,
I didn't that head Trump thinks that he won with is Samsung and iPhone.
Trump is so oblivious to what is happening.
Trump's greatest flaw,
and this triggers Trump supporters.
But that's the beauty of being French.
I can trigger everybody and make them mad.
A good leaders worried about the troops,
good leaders like what's going on with the troops.
He doesn't care.
Trump cares about Trump and it always triggers.
I'll probably lose 5,000 Twitter followers.
I don't care.
Actually,
I got rid of most of them.
But Trump cares about Trump.
So in Trump's world,
he's not thinking about these people downstream.
He,
you know,
he's living his own life or whatever.
Then he has to be an odd sort of disconnect because obviously what catapulted
him was to be in touch with that.
But do you think that's just the nature of now you've attained power,
so you just started to disconnect from that phone?
No,
no.
I mean,
I've talked to people with personal knowledge and everything.
No,
no,
he doesn't.
He doesn't think the Facebook ads,
Cambridge Analytica band,
he just thinks he won with this phone.
That that has really Trump the beauty of Trump.
And this is why every time I criticized him,
I smile too because he is unlike anything we've ever had,
at least in my lifetime.
And the beauty of him is that he's so self confident that you can't take them
down.
I mean if the media went after me,
the way they went after him,
I'd probably would have a panic attack or something and probably have PTSD.
But that self confidence is also based in it adjusted total self involvement.
Where in his world he's like,
I just tweet it in.
The magic happens.
She doesn't realize.
No,
I mean there's network nodes and there's ways messaging get across.
It just doesn't work this way.
So do you think he's a failure then the,
I mean this strikes me that the free speech stuff in the platform stuff.
I mean,
you know,
that's my,
my core stuff.
I mean do you think he's a failure then it,
if,
if everything you're sort of predicting here is going to happen,
it's a leadership failure.
Yeah.
He failed when,
when he fired General Flynn and he let General Flynn plead guilty and he didn't
pardon General Flynn.
That was a major failing.
It's one that I will not forgive and people,
uh,
so what people that understand is generally there's a deep state or whatever,
which is just another way of thinking of that bureaucracy.
The people,
you're going to go to DC and you think you're hot shit,
your AOC or hot.
There's people that are before you and there's people who are going to be there
after you leave.
Is that how you would describe deep state?
Because I know people are going to say Ruben had conspiracy theorist.
That's another one.
I forgot about that one.
Yeah,
so deep,
deep state is you think you're hot shit.
It's just like Hollywood,
the stig industry.
When people talk about Hollywood,
they talk about the industry.
I'm a big star now.
You've got three years.
Billy Cory talked about this and Joe Rogan,
you've got three years,
Mr Corgan smashing pumpkins.
The industry is going to be there before you.
It's going to be there after you.
And the deep state is essentially that the bureaucracy,
this Byzantium complex of people and networks.
So you could argue whether that's good or bad.
Right,
right.
And why it may be has to exist in some you there all three are a bit,
right,
but,
but it's not a conspiracy.
You're not saying that there's some sort of,
cause I think people think automatically,
you mean that there's some sort of group that is some sort of shadowy,
right,
right.
That's because they don't fit well there,
there isn't.
There isn't.
I mean there's,
I've been part of conspiracies,
everybody's been part of a conspiracy.
Ryan Holiday's book conspiracy.
I wasn't part of that conspiracy,
but that was a conspiracy.
So in Gawker was a conspiracy and actual conspiracy orchestra by Peter Teal and
Mr [inaudible] or Mr axe or whatever.
And they took down Gawker.
So the deep state conspiracy and shifts in terms of there were people that were
pro Trump and they saw what Trump did.
A General Flynn got out peace CEO,
you know,
when you leave town,
that was a major leadership failing.
His is a major moral failing of him.
General Flynn had Trump's back when that meant something and that was hard.
Now everybody,
Oh,
you know,
you can,
you can graft,
you can make all that money off of him.
Whatever Flynn had Trump's backs,
I won't forgive that.
And the,
the good guys or whatever the deep state people want to talk about.
So He's,
that's absolutely a moral failing as solution failing.
And a largely that has to deal with his energy,
has masculine energy,
is still very shadow.
He isn't that fully integrated,
fully self possessed man who realizes you're a servant leader,
you're president,
United States,
whatever.
Uh,
you never heard me say hardly anything about about Obama.
I still want to this day didn't like his policy.
Obama had a sense outside of himself and Trump doesn't have that sense of,
you know what,
I'm,
this is a major responsibility.
Now the flip side is if Trump felt that way,
he might have a nervous breakdown because of the attacks.
And this was all very complicated.
You know,
you're serious.
Be Weird and warped psychological,
uh,
situation because it's like,
yeah,
if he was maybe more evolved,
let's say all the hate would probably get to the middle way that would crush any
human being's.
Exactly.
And yet he's not.
So it offers the defense,
which is allowing him
to functions.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's something I've spent a lot of time thinking about Trump.
And even when I think about,
and even when I'm criticizing guy,
just by smile,
there's just this affection where it's like son of a bitch actually.
So he is right.
And if he weren't that person,
nobody could have withstood the attacks that Trump was stood,
no human being ever problem.
I don't know from the history of the world,
but you'd be crushed.
And everyday he just kept showing up.
He doesn't have,
you know how the presidency agents people and that he does,
he's a 72 year old man.
I think he's 50 right in my mind.
Right.
I read his books.
It's going to be aging the way there's no stick.
Exactly.
You know,
cause he doesn't have that moral complexity and the nuance that would,
when you walk in you're like,
holy fuck man,
I'm president.
I'd stays.
What the fuck is this?
Right?
You just get in like,
Yep,
Oval Office,
son of a bitch,
bring me a diet coke.
Change those,
change the drapes,
drapes or ugly.
We need to refurbish this old dusty place.
Yeah.
What?
Okay.
If for the people watching this that are going to selectively edit it,
that no matter what either of us say,
gonna do whatever they're going to do.
If you were to try to offer a little out of this mutually assured destruction,
what,
what would you want out of them?
What would you want to see that might get us out of this mess?
I don't think you want to be suing these guys.
And,
and you know,
you were explaining some of this stuff with,
with your daughter and your wife before,
and you can expand on it here if you want,
but I know that's not fun.
That's not right.
Well,
there's,
there's different layers to it.
So one is to the really creepy,
evil people.
They're always gonna be creeping evil.
And I'm dealing with them in ways that they,
yeah,
they have no idea.
Um,
but the people in the middle,
the people who they are,
they're on my beat.
This is what gets me there.
Are they everything I do,
they tweet about,
they write about,
they know what's happening.
Say The fucking right thing.
Just say,
you know what?
I don't like Cernovich he's a scumbag.
This is fucked up.
No more of this bullshit.
Call Your own side.
That would be my message.
Because if they don't,
people are going to get more and more and more militant.
There's no reason the world,
multiple reporters attend my events.
If a Jewish guy gets,
it shouldn't matter that you show,
which by just bringing up to show how complicated it is or why Antifa guy beats
up a Jewish Trump supporter.
But the article in the Guardian is angry white men party with Cernovich.
No,
no,
no.
The angry white man beat the fuck out of some Jewish guy.
No,
no,
no.
You're just,
you're just liars.
So the decent people in the middle,
hey,
I don't need you to love me.
You can dislike me,
that's fine.
But if you know something's wrong,
I don't,
none of this.
I was my side.
Don't pretend like you don't know.
Don't pretend like it's not on your beat.
Don't pretend like you can't write about it when you write about everything else
that I do or that happens to me.
Just do the right thing.
Have some integrity,
a gut check time for everybody.
Yeah,
and likewise,
likewise,
I call that the minute that solute bull shit happened.
I was right there like,
who are these people that Nazis Lou thing.
You know I was Ca Kovich and you know k.
I.
K.
E.
O.
Yeah,
I was,
you know,
every,
I was the victim of antisemitic slurs,
which shows you what weird world we live in.
But I just said,
all right dude,
like Nazi salutes.
Okay.
This was what I thought it was.
I thought you guys were just,
you know,
trying to have different ideas.
You're bad people and the left 34 this is violence.
Call it out.
Part of the problem that they,
we sort of hit on this early,
but they can always get away with it.
Like the machine somehow moves to always let them get away with it.
So for example,
when Biden put out his,
his video announcing that he was running for president,
it was based on the lie that Trump was saying that there were good people on
both sides of the Charlottesville,
uh,
marches.
And it's very clear right before that nobody shows it.
But Trump said,
and his language,
you looked,
the way he speaks is weird.
His sentence structure is weird.
He backs up and forwards and reverses around and does all these,
these weird things and maybe there'll be a book written none on the psychology
of why he speaks that way or whatever,
or all his strange,
his strains,
intonations and all that.
But he clearly didn't say they were good people on both sides,
meaning that the Nazi side was good.
He met some of the people that didn't want the statue taken down.
We're good.
And he condemn the races and the way now she's,
but they know they can get away with it.
So every few months the video just goes viral again because CNN people retweet
it and the blue check and it's like,
man,
okay,
well that's called,
let's call the erosion of trust and the these people,
they,
if you're,
here's the way I try to explain to people who don't live in this bizarre will
that you live in.
And I live in probably in the weeds a little bit,
even more than you do,
which is,
you know,
imagine,
I don't know,
whoever made this glass company thing,
I drank it and I buy a piece of glass,
goes in my mouth and I report on,
I'm bleeding and it'd be like a PR crisis.
Town halls,
what is going on?
Like when Tylenol had contaminated bottles.
Yeah.
Town halls,
brand trust.
You now have,
even Democrats don't trust the media anymore.
This should be treated if you're in the media and you believe so.
Like,
let's just say I'm,
I'm a,
I'm thinking in terms of a good journalist acting in good faith and I'm speaking
to a journalist back in good faith,
you don't have any influence anymore because you won't call out your side.
So then when you do attack me or other people or even people who are
legitimately bad,
nobody's going to believe you.
You'll never take off the Jacob Walls in the world.
Why?
Because even I don't believe the articles I read a bottom Micah,
you know,
maybe he did.
Maybe you didn't.
The probably just making it up.
I just don't believe it.
And if you're a journalist and you really want to tell the truth and you want to
speak truth to power,
you're done.
It's over.
You don't have any influence.
And the only power,
they don't think about this because they're not philosophical people.
The media's power comes from moral legitimacy.
There's this thing,
I wrote it.
You read it.
You realize that what you're reading about is bad and you want to take some kind
of action.
The minute assault,
tabloid gossip,
you're not going to take any action.
They'll never be able to effectuate a change,
so that's what we're getting.
We're too far gone on this because that's sort of where I'm realizing now.
It's like,
okay,
you know,
2040 years ago we had ABC,
CBS,
NBC.
They were all basically within a certain prison,
one lean one way,
one lean the other,
but it was you basically as a nation got a certain amount of similar
information.
Now we split it off a gajillion different ways.
There's a lot of good out of that and it's allowed other voices and I would say
I'm included that it's allowed me to do this so I'm not complaining about it
fully,
but that the ultimate risk is we will continue to just crumble off into
different ways that you are going to be walking down the street and it'll be
basically like everybody that you look at will be living in another digital
world and then what does that leave us in reality?
Yeah.
There's multiple ways to thinking about,
one is a term people are going to hear more and more about us fortune,
aeration warfare for Gw,
which is just the idea of you have decentralized armies now where the army's
aren't in a uniform and you don't know who it is and who isn't.
Right.
It's decentralized.
Very Philip k Dick.
Yeah.
And now we're in a world where it's decentralized mimetics where,
well there's nobody really,
even Joe Rogan said this,
he goes,
he said,
I used to watch CNN and I don't even trust CNN anymore.
That used to be,
ah,
that's what,
yeah,
that's why they got bad ratings because they were honest and nuanced and
everything like that.
And I think less of probably about this society is going to fracture.
And then I think,
well I remember we had in bend,
that's the way it was.
We went to Vietnam,
killed a bunch of people,
get,
you know,
dump,
dumped all this chemicals,
Agent Orange on them.
I've been in museums and Vietnam,
the d,
The form faces and the landmines is still there.
And because of what the US did in Vietnam and flew over Cambodian airspace at
Kramer Rouge rose up and they're still a little children with legs being blown
off because their mind fields everywhere we were United.
So United American,
we got Vietnam War,
we've got the war in Iraq based on lies about WMDs.
We had the Cold War scare is a de centralized world where you actually have to
consensus.
Maybe that's better.
Maybe it's better that you have to say,
you know what,
you might not like these people,
but you know,
you're,
you can work together on an issue.
You have to have some kind of consensus now rather than a centralized authority
figure telling you what to do or what to think.
Or it could be awful.
Right.
And then that,
that is the unanswered question I suppose.
But it's so interesting because I do see for whatever,
whatever frustrations or distance I have with some of the people on the right
right now,
and we've talked about some of them here.
It's like I see these people willing to talk about things and it's like they're,
I don't meet any racist.
Well,
I only get invited by conservatives and Libertarians and people on the right.
I don't see any racist.
I don't see bigots.
I don't see homophobes,
I don't see misogynists any of these things.
I see something very rich and interesting happening there and it's not what I
ever would have thought because I was only getting information from one side.
Well you're being told what to think and this idea that you passively consume
news,
and this is ironically that Sophie video she talked about the same thing she
said were Gen z,
we don't trust anything.
And by the way,
that's why people,
how do people know I was falsely accused of rape?
Well I knew some gen Z or we'll find it out somehow because these people are so
smart,
you know,
whatever.
So you just,
you get out,
you just put your apo out there.
You're just say,
look,
here's all the apo on me,
here's all the apple on that.
Let's just bare our souls.
And then let people decide whether to,
you know,
like you are not like you are recognize that most people are complicated.
And you know,
for example,
Tupac went to prison for rape,
but they don't want the band to Bach's music from the radio.
Why?
Why is that?
I mean,
he literally went to prison for four years for rape.
The new Michael Jackson document.
Exactly.
And it's like nobody's taking those songs off the radio.
And I'm not saying they should,
should the weird.
Right,
right.
But it's this weird thing where we selectively pick Roseanne's got to get her
syndication taken out.
But
yeah,
so we have decentralized network where he and I have to have consensus.
And again,
that's why the blue check marks get so frustrated and angry is,
and their world,
they're very important people and know they're not there.
Their legitimacy comes from the publications they work on,
but they're shitting on their publications so much by just running garbage for
the people don't even believe them anymore.
So now what do you have to do?
You have to,
again,
you have to be an adult.
Kaitlin Johnstone,
she got a bunch of heat because,
you know,
some of my views are economic populous,
which left wing,
but I believe in a living wage.
I don't know that I believe $15 is the right amendment wage,
Duh Duh Duh Duh.
But,
um,
some of my ideas would be quite offensive to you,
including that I think CEO pay should be tagged to the median worker salary.
I don't think you should have a see a 300 and I'm,
you know,
going far left man that right.
So if your,
if your,
um,
left eight,
you're like,
well,
I think service is kind of a bad guy.
Don't really like them that much,
but,
but that's a good idea.
Why don't you know,
we worked together on that idea or,
or not,
but,
but those are the conversations people are going to have.
Now you cancerous come out and say,
this is the way it is or this is the way it was.
And people blind,
they believe you and you.
So give me,
give me some predictions because uh,
I know people love being in the prediction game.
So you've been sort of critical at Trump here,
but I know you have a sort of basic,
you sorta like it still,
or at least better than the alternatives.
What do you think's going to happen here?
They're,
the Democrats are having a knife fight.
They should have won 20,
20.
It should be no problem.
But there and me,
I was,
I'm Kinda like you like first trimester on abortion.
You know,
I'm a little squishy on that.
Um,
but I'm becoming like just a pro lifer because you'd see this Brian Sims guy
harassing teenage indeed.
It's like frick all these people.
And unfortunately that is that.
Well,
let's just sit with them for a second because that is that another perfect
example of the double standards.
It's like if that had been a young conservative,
big buff,
conservative,
uh,
politicians,
state senator,
anywhere else doing something reverse,
so it wasn't at an abortion clinic,
um,
the media would have destroyed him and they would have said,
this is Trump's America.
This is the evil and the patriarchy and all of those things.
And instead,
did CNN even touch the pieces,
made it,
did they cover the,
the,
the rally that happened after or any of them?
No,
they ignore it.
Or if they ignore it,
the story becomes a backlash.
Right?
If we're nine pounds,
they pounces on this guy.
You guys are always bouncing.
Exactly.
And what gets me is that's it.
He should be banned from social media.
He used periscope to insight.
He offered money to docs under age girls.
Yeah.
And so let's go to their house.
Okay.
There is no and no world is that not you get banned.
And this by the way happened,
what?
Two days after the,
the Alex Jones,
Paul Joseph Watson,
right,
exactly.
It's like,
okay bro,
you gotta be in it.
And that's where you're learning that the social media companies,
they're not regulating behavior.
They're regulating ideas because if you're regulating behavior and patron had
the same problem with you,
they came in and he said,
we only regulate behavior.
And he calmed me.
Everybody believes in me.
It just came off as so credible.
Like,
well what a sociopath.
And you know,
he just sat here and was like,
yeah,
no ideas are off limit.
When he said manifest observable behavior,
which is the acronym is mob,
I should've known something was wrong.
That was memetically.
I found that interesting.
She was,
we followed the mob rule.
And I'm a rule.
And then even then you're like,
well,
I mean Lauren southern was in the boat and I don't think she actually did it,
but you could at least there are things where you can disagree,
but you're like,
why are you see where you're coming from?
I think he made the wrong choice,
but I recognize your reasoning and there's rule and now you realize,
no,
they're just there.
They're saying ideas are off limits.
You can't talk about certain things.
You know what my final Straw was with them,
sorry to interrupt,
but it was when,
when the thing happened with Sargon and I called him,
I texted him first,
we got on the phone for a second and he immediately said,
you'll never be banned.
Like jumped before I even said anything.
And I thought,
well that means I'm going to be bad.
You know what I mean?
Like you'll never be bad at it as if that would've been enough for me.
Oh well bad everybody else.
But as long as I'm okay,
we're good to go,
you know,
bright and he,
but,
but his rule was around idea behavior.
Okay.
You're out in public.
If you're out in public saying,
I have these bad ideas.
Okay.
You know,
maybe we shouldn't.
Maybe that's preventing a certain kind of culture.
I can at least see the reasoning,
but this guy is inciting the docks of underage girls sims.
Now we're talking about,
yeah,
yeah.
Now we're,
yeah,
we're not talking about patriot.
We're talking about this Philadelphia guy under,
no,
that's a use case.
You're just like,
okay,
you got to ban them and if you don't ban him,
then you don't.
You can't,
you have no rules.
If that guy,
you won't be banned.
Or if I trolled the way I used the troll in 2015 you know,
I don't think a lot of people would shed any tears like,
well,
I mean you shouldn't be calling people fat.
This is kind of being,
you know,
just Duh,
Duh,
but behavior,
it isn't ideas,
but they're targeting ideas and not targeting behavior.
And if you're on the left,
you can do whatever you want to do on social media.
Are you saying the ship,
the ship has sailed,
then you think it's that it's over.
Trump's not going to fix this.
Even if it was in his purview to fix this,
you think it's just,
Oh,
like it seems like all stories will still come back to this,
this issue.
There's massive college.
So for first of all,
I said this at the beginning of the last year is going to get worse.
It's going to get worse.
Social media platforms is just scratching the surface.
You won't be able to have a bank account.
You're going to be on a hate and it's already happening.
Alex Jones is happening to Laura Loomer is happening in a few other people.
You want to be able to have a bank out.
Now,
the problem with mass human psychology is it tends towards an overcorrection.
And if I,
and I gotta be careful how I say this because I disavow any kind of violence,
but that's always been my position.
That said,
they're creating people with no livelihood.
Okay?
So you can't have a voice.
You can't have a bank account.
Those people are either going to go homeless or we're going to have our own
homegrown jihad is,
but they're not Muslims.
They'll be on,
we're creating literally,
which the lesson of terror,
and this is why I don't like the way of Trump people talk about Muslims,
I'm going to lose 5,000 more.
I don't care.
I've,
I've ever tweeted it repeatedly over and over again or tweak this a lot.
I discussed it.
It's disgusting.
No,
and not only that,
but you radicalize moderate Muslims because they're like,
well fuck it.
These people hate me.
But you know,
at least those people,
modern Muslims are killed more by the jihadis than any other group of people.
So I see the stuff and I'm just not only subjectively disgusted,
but the strategically,
this is not smart.
You want to show people no,
no,
we have a release valve.
So what we're doing now is we're creating our own jihadis.
You know,
she,
hot is a poor word,
but they're like,
okay,
you can't make a living.
You can't have a voice.
You can have a bank account.
So you can either go be homeless somewhere,
you know,
they'll commit suicide or something.
Or we know what happens.
We see what happens in the Islamic world.
We see what happens when you leave a little pockets of people to radicalize
versus not difficult to see.
This is mass ecology,
the also this
pleasure in the destruction of people.
And again,
you've said at the beginning of this,
you've traded in some of this.
It's like when,
when Laura Loomer was changed outside of Twitter or when she went to Pelosi's
house or any of this,
doesn't even matter what I think about Laura Loomer or whatever I met,
I met her once briefly.
Um,
the pleasure that I saw people taking in,
Oh,
this woman,
this,
this is a human being.
She has been destroyed.
You d person,
her,
your unperson here and,
and,
and maybe she's having a mental breakdown or I,
I have no idea.
You know what I mean?
I actually have sympathy for her in regard,
but it's
like the pleasure that you watch.
The,
the good guys,
the tolerant people taken destroying people.
I mean,
that is a road to hell right there.
Howard bloom talks about that and the Lucifer principle and there's,
you know,
like there's,
they're kind of like a reading list.
The human nature,
pessimists reading list would be Howard Bloom,
Lucifer principle,
and then sapiens.
And then,
I dunno,
uh,
Jordan Peterson podcast.
It's something,
but the idea that there's an inherent kind of evil and all of us and Western
civilization and,
and you know,
there was,
this is another thing too,
I don't like about the people who,
you know,
attacking.
There were Islamic civilizations in a Syrian culture long before Western
civilization.
So the Confucian culture is quite beautiful Japanese Shinto culture.
But the idea of civilization had attains people in a,
in a way that's productive and healthy and good,
but there's always that nastiness inside of all of us that the inner chimpanzee
and you should,
you should police fat,
not trust in yourself and others.
And when people are saying,
lol,
a little lower limb is going to kill herself.
Okay.
That's actually not funny.
You know,
that's not,
that isn't funny at all.
This is funny that she is having these problems and these kinds of challenges
and what's worse is there's no road to reformation.
There's no road to redemption.
What do you do?
She's 24.
Well,
what are you going to do with somebody like that?
And people should think about that just on a human level,
but they should also think about it as a societal of assistance DEMEC level.
Is it good that we're making people who have nothing to lose?
Is that good for the social order?
It's actually quite disastrous.
People take it for granted because they're Glib and they haven't lived through
real adversity and maybe they haven't even read history.
You there parts of the world,
you're just,
you know,
we're right here,
boom,
car car bomb goes off.
Do you think a lot of that is just sort of a function of western success that we
don't know?
I mean,
we're roughly the same age.
You know,
it's been,
it's been a pretty good ride.
It been a great run and it was a better run before us because,
uh,
the United States at a time post World War II had a booming economy.
They have low immigration.
So you had all this space,
the California dream,
and have a good job.
People middle class lifestyle in California used to be,
you'd have a house,
two cars,
take a two week vacation,
maybe have a boat that was just like a normal middle class life.
Now that's like a millionaire life,
right?
I'm gonna [inaudible] bunker.
Right,
right,
right.
Exactly.
And so we all got spoiled.
We all got used to it.
And then the problem everybody's making is you have left wing populism,
which is radical socialism,
which has been tried.
We know how that ends empirically on how it ends.
And then we have right wing populous.
And that's how people describe it is I'm like,
I'm economic populous.
What does that mean?
I care about the median wage earner when I'm at Costco and I'm walking out and
there's a person whose job is to check my receipt.
I'm like,
ah,
you know,
I hope that person is able to pay their bills.
I hope that person is able to maybe have a little bit of leisure time.
One thing AOC said that I liked,
and this is why people who sleep on her making mistake is there's the sense that
as a human being and the richest country in the world,
the only conference you deserve,
our animalistic her words,
she's so good.
Or whoever is their handlers,
animalistic,
animalistic desires.
And I thought,
what a great way to frame it,
where you're saying you're conservatives.
You think only people have the right as of their base animalistic desires,
and we want something more and the human spirit always wants something more.
There's always this aspirational vision and those are my views.
Yet we do.
We want the difference between me and the left and the Socialists.
I want you to have a living wage,
but to have a living wage,
we have to,
we have to cap immigration because it's a basic supply and demand issue.
This is just basic economics.
Somehow we forget this and we want people to have a good way to,
we want people to have those.
Libertarians would disagree with you,
even though you said you were,
you sort of have a lot of libertarian leanings.
They would say the pure libertarians would say open the borders,
no tires,
and let's pretend there's no democracy and people wouldn't come in and vote for
liberty.
You had that.
That's the beauty of the libertarian position.
It's kind of like the NRO capitalism,
you know,
they have,
I like it intellectually.
I mean that's what I would say when I have some,
I've had some of these medical guys on and it's like,
I like it intellectually,
but I,
but this is where I would say a classical liberal,
it's just slightly basically like a more realistic libertarian.
Yeah.
Look,
what are you going to do when they come in and we abide by the nonaggression
principle.
Great.
That's not human nature.
What are you gonna do when they come in and take your shit?
We need weapons,
but guess what would you give men weapons?
This is the problem where like libertarianism in capitalist and it's a very sort
of male brain,
completely ignorant of history and just human nature and human psychology where
you're like,
okay,
but when you,
if you follow the nonaggression principle and you give men guns,
they don't just keep falling.
The nonaggression principle that changes the psychology.
Now you have an army,
will armies do things,
mission,
creed.
This is again,
mass ecology.
More people should read extraordinary delusions and popular madness of crowds
and you're like,
oh,
people talk about the Salem witch trials.
Okay,
we have a witch trials now you're a witch.
You're racist.
You're home.
Okay,
this is all happening in the differences.
They would burn them literally.
Although actually it's a historical,
not that many people being burned.
This is something that comes part of the popular myth,
those,
but now we're making people in a way,
we're making it so people can't make a living,
which is,
I don't,
I don't want to say it's worse than killing a person,
but that's,
I mean,
think about it.
I got a guide,
a fired once.
I felt really bad about it.
It wasn't,
it wasn't,
I did nothing wrong so to speak,
but just on a human level.
And I was like,
um,
you know,
it's kind of rough.
I report it truthfully on what he said and blah,
blah,
blah.
And,
but this guy will be fine.
He was Harvard educated,
privileged,
and you think about it,
your executing people,
this is but,
but,
but meanwhile are you got to take a lot of people out to get to their youtube,
but if you're in prison,
you better come.
Well,
yeah,
but I love the left is,
Oh,
you,
oh you,
you commit you prison.
You got to come back into society.
Oh,
you made a bad tweet.
You made a bad joke.
You said a bad thing.
You said a bad thing about Muslims.
Loomer you know,
like the Uber thing,
you know,
I was like,
Loomer what are you doing bro?
Come on man.
Come on.
You know,
I love it.
I love the kid,
but I'm like,
come on Bro.
But that said that that doesn't give you your executed.
You don't deserve,
that doesn't merit that behavior.
That Marissa behavior.
Like,
Hey,
you need to come on in and like,
come on Bro,
this is,
this is bullshit.
And there's no sense of that.
They want to crush and destroy people.
So what's going to happen,
it's going to be at the trends are,
and I said this a year and a half ago,
domestic terrorism,
America's you similar come like a way of life,
which is just going to be like a thing like in Beirut or whatever.
You're drinking,
your espresso and everything and there's always going to be this cloud is that
something could pop off at any time because everybody's being radicalized,
everybody's being attacked.
And I,
I'm the guy here,
like,
please don't,
don't let this happen.
There's way too ways to avoid it.
Studied the Islamic world study high,
treat moderate Islams.
Uh,
you know,
you've got to have a pipeline for people.
And I don't like to say that with us.
My prediction.
Why do you think you haven't been booted?
Why were you not included in this whole crew?
I broke a number of reasons.
One is I broke a lot of legitimate news stories.
So I went from troll whenever that is to commentate or whatever that is to like
know,
like Susan Ryan,
say like I broke that.
I'm asking you.
So this is a big story.
I broken a lot of legitimately newsworthy subjects and I cleaned up my act.
Um,
there,
there are just certain things.
Well,
and also to luck,
I've never cared about the transgender thing other than they have a tough go
hold there.
Only two genders.
Fucking Glib.
I don't,
I don't like that.
This is Glib.
These are people.
Body dysmorphia is a serious thing,
you know,
there's just that really nastiness under earner current of a lot of this
rhetoric all over.
So I've never really cared about that other than the,
you know,
this is there.
They got a tough go,
you know,
I'm not going to add to that and this on stuff,
I've always been like,
you know,
I don't like the way people talk about it.
And those are the two triggers right now.
So if you're a trans folk or an Islamophobe,
that right now is what's getting people going to get people moved away.
And I just happened to fall on the right side of the issue.
And then also there,
there was a sense I was breaking real news and so it just,
I think I just did the lines moved and I just barely made it.
All right,
so how do,
if we had to,
we did some predictions in some way,
but if we have to predict what the blue check guys watching this right now,
what are they going to write about?
Um,
number of things.
One is that they don't write about it at all.
They didn't write about hoaxed 106 countries.
I did,
I played a little trick on them when I released the trailer for hoaxed.
I deleted every tweet other than the trailer.
And you know what they wrote about Cernovich deletes tweets trying to cover his
butt.
They didn't write about the trailer.
Why?
Cause it looked good because you're like,
Whoa,
this is a real production,
real quality film.
They never went after Jordan Peterson for being in the film.
So I was,
I predicted for sure.
I'm like poor Jordan.
Cause when Jordan did it,
he was,
you know,
he wasn't Jordan fucking Peterson.
He was like Jordan here said,
you know,
hi,
how are you?
I was bigger than him at the time actually.
So he was happy to be at,
you know.
Yeah.
And they never went after him for it because the film is so good,
they don't actually want people watching it.
So this interview I think is so powerful that the angry little weird left
people.
The freaks,
the one weird Mike and the people who support my family being harassed.
They'll do all the dunking on Twitter,
but no outlet media.
I may be maybe gutter gutter,
stuff like that.
I'll put a little thing here,
there.
The daily beast,
a little gutter thing there.
Daily beast by the way,
they take money from Qatar.
Isn't that interesting?
Interesting.
How foreign influence is a real problem.
Mike Cernovich homophobe guitar,
you go to jail for being gay,
but we'll take your money.
Well,
the doe,
her forearm and flies first class and everything like this.
But other than the real gutter outlets,
it'll be ignored in the gunner.
Outlist might ignore it too,
because they don't want people to see the full unedited conversation.
I mean,
would you just can't,
it's like,
here's my past to Phillip said,
here's what I've done.
I don't have any fear of confronting it that that bothers them because they,
they want the cray car coachers and they're not able to create a car.
Katra so I think like with hoax movie,
they'll pretend this never happened.
I'm going to actually look down while sitting right in front of you to see if we
hit on all the,
all the big stuff here.
Yeah,
we pretty,
we pretty much did let the chips fall where they may,
I suppose.
Uh,
my pleasure.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's unfortunate office of Mike ibn and we forgot to talk about him.
Who,
um,
he's like orthodox Jewish Trump supporter.
Oh,
this is the guy that did the Michael Moore.
Oh wait,
let's,
yeah,
so this is the guy who did the parody,
AOC press,
Twitter accounts,
which said it was a parody 100% yes.
This is allowed to be on Twitter.
They booted him about a week ago.
Yup.
And that's because he was too effective?
Yeah.
One of the things he tweeted out,
it showed up on my timeline and I was like,
oh,
that's funny.
It was actually a real tweet copy and pasted from AOC because some of the things
she said are there beyond,
it's like Poe's law.
You don't even know if it's true or not.
And because he was funny in effective band,
so,
okay.
So they banned this guy for parity.
Even though they say you're allowed to have parody accounts,
as long as you say it's a parody account.
Now of course they're not abandoned.
All the Trump parody accounts,
and I'm sure there's more than two.
There's Cerner,
there's Cernovich parody account.
I mean there's,
I'm sure there's,
we haven't,
they,
they fricking make them every day and they blow and I block them and then they
make more of them the same,
you know,
the same people over and over.
Okay,
fine.
Who Cares?
Yeah.
Um,
so what,
what happened to this guy?
I mean they just banned them.
They claimed cause then they ban his real account to right being as real account
and they claimed his name by the way,
Mike,
the office of Michael Suspect.
I think his last name's Morrison,
but I'm not really sure.
Okay.
Yeah.
But he's a cool guy.
He's been to all the Trump things and he was just,
he was just too effective and they to claim that he was coordinating with other
accounts.
But they wouldn't tell you why or how.
And I mean you want to talk about these guys that we've been talking about,
this whole,
this whole blue check crew.
I mean they coordinate with anonymous accounts.
Exactly.
Can you explain a little bit of that?
Because I know this is going on.
I have my ways that I know also,
and some of these people have real stupid cause they keep trying to get me,
but it's like they're,
they're using anonymous accounts that seem like it's nobody to selectively edit
the videos.
Then suddenly all the daily beast and vox and Huffpo reporters at both of you
guys,
they then retweet it all and it's like,
well that's strange.
You retweet in,
uh,
an account with six followers.
And it's like,
it's like,
how'd you find this information laundering?
And here's the way information laundering works.
You have something as a reporter that you couldn't post on your own thing
because you know it's garbage.
So you either yourself,
and I think a lot of times it's them,
you either yourself or through these other bot networks,
have some them in a throwaway account,
put this video up,
and then you have the level below.
You start to retweet it and then you say,
oh,
there's this video.
I'm not vouching for the truth or falsity of it,
but here's this thing out there that I could talk about now.
And that's how they launder information.
That's what that guy,
I am 99% sure I want to get this wrong,
but I think it was the CEO or the editor in chief,
I think of gaining knowledge.
Oh,
they did was they went after me and you know,
one of these,
I'm all right.
Whatever it is,
they take this quote where I say the alt right from years ago when the,
all right,
we're still much more a morphous.
I say the thing about it being,
you know,
let's say this about the racist.
No,
good.
Then I say this thing about the joke makers in the meme makers,
one of they,
somebody selectively edited a random anonymous guy.
The editor in chief then retweets it.
And then I say to him,
well,
how come you didn't put it in the previous sentence?
Then he ignores me.
It's like,
exactly.
And so that's one way the information launder.
Another way that they do is they do have bots.
So there's been articles,
this is what I love about being a lefty.
There's articles,
um,
there's people again on Twitter claiming they have revenge porn of me.
And as long as I'm in good shape,
you know,
but it's technically a sex crime.
That's sexual harassment.
By the way,
this is again us,
you know me being glib because I live online so much.
So could you imagine if I tweet it out,
I have a sex tape of Anderson Cooper and I'm going to post it on Twitter.
How long would I survive Twitter?
30 seconds.
Five minutes.
But they,
oh yeah,
we have a sex tape.
We're going to post it.
Here is a picture of Cernovich with his genitals blown out and are blurred out.
And we're going to post this and here's no problem.
Not only that,
but the daily beast,
which again,
they'd have taken money from Qatar.
They wrote an article saying far right wing trolls get a dose of their own
medicine.
And the article was,
ha ha ha.
Isn't it funny that this is happening to Cernovich is failing?
Rolling Stone wrote a piece.
Oh,
isn't it funny that Cernovich's wife is getting death threats because,
oh lol.
So not only,
so either they,
so they information launder or they characterize it a ways.
It's kind of funny,
but they're there.
They're making a mistake because they admit that these people use bots.
And that's why I'm linking it back to the Bob thing.
Yeah.
Because when they write about a splinter wrote an article about two people who
harass you and the same people who were asked my family,
they,
there's an article going,
oh,
they're using bots to troll the alt right.
It's like,
oh.
So in other words,
you're admitting that you're using bots and that's,
and that's how they phrase it.
And one of the articles is actually how I found at the AOC was actually
roommates with one of the people going after my wife and daughter.
So,
so there's a lot of things in play in that regard.
But yeah,
the media admits the far left wing or they call them weird Twitter or whatever
they admit the weird left uses bobs and that's all being overlooked.
Now the problem with Twitter,
if we're looking at chess pieces,
is do they think,
I don't talk to people in Congress,
right?
They do.
The congressman talked to me in public,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
you can,
you can see it.
So all of this stuff that the media is using to say,
lol,
isn't it funny?
Cernovich's wife is getting death threats and his daughter getting death
threats.
Hahaha.
It's good for him.
It's like you,
you think that I haven't not only sent that to every reporter who says that.
So one day they'll get sued,
they'll get gawkers that'll all turn up in discovery.
I've sent out to every legal department of Facebook and I building that dossier
in Congress.
So they have no idea.
They basically the social media companies who think they're getting away with
these double standards there,
that you just take a step back and think that if it's Mike Cernovich who's very
nice to people now he's getting death rescues his wife and child,
you think that he's not doing something about that behind the scenes.
Do you think it's weird that this is what your life is this absurd?
Yeah.
Uh,
I think about every day how I ruined my life by ever becoming a public figure.
And I could just write my books and live a good life and nobody knew who I was
and were for Trump ran.
I was in a Parisian cafe just riding,
having fun with my wife,
walking around,
looking in Notredame before it burned down and everything.
And every day I think I ruined my life by becoming a public figure because just
the fundamental and decency of it all is not something that I was prepared for.
I'm prepared for a hit,
but when it's my family being targeted and the same people who hit me and follow
everything I do can't say something about that,
that that does make you in a way,
it makes you sad.
And the problem with making people like me sad is sometimes I hold my daughter
and I think about the people who are trying to hurt her and I think about the
people who know is happening and they're not saying anything about it and I wish
that they would do the right thing.
I wish the media would do the right thing and start policing themselves and quit
pretending like it isn't newsworthy and quit pretending new knowledge.
Here's a great example of two new knowledge.
The CEO,
they talk about disinformation,
but he got caught buying Russian boss or people and then he goes to the news and
the news says,
oh,
according to the CEO of new knowledge,
Russian boss falling Roy Moore.
But when he bought the box and then Renee,
I forget her last name,
goes on,
Sam Harris goes into a broken Russian bots,
conspiracy theorists far right people.
I was like,
wait a minute,
what?
What about your CEO though by People Bob's.
So this,
this idea,
this,
this information that's all these people that write about disinformation and I
always email them at their official work office so that everybody knows and I
always CCH Ron legal just so there's a record because one day,
one thing you are going to get sued and then that'll turn up like,
well yeah,
why didn't,
why didn't you write about these threats?
But if you write about this information,
why don't you write about this inflammation on the left?
How many articles are there about,
did you get,
there's this information about you,
they don't correct it.
And this is again,
is going to just further radicalize people further,
eliminate public trust and take society in a bad direction.
All right,
so let's just do one more thing to really troll the trolls here.
So all the people,
let's say that some of these blue check guys are gonna write some of this stuff
and buzzfeed and the rest of it.
Is there anything that you would like to say directly about the alt right about
white supremacy,
about do
any of that?
I'll give them a headline for,
I'll give them a headline about Trump because this is something I was talking to
'em because what people don't realize is yeah,
we always have Jews,
Orthodox Jews at 90% pro Trump,
right?
You just,
you don't see people with the kippah and you know,
the Hasidic Jewish community.
So I was,
I was taken aside by very,
uh,
a very kind person and he goes,
you know,
I wish you had said something more about,
this is two years ago.
It's like,
oh,
we should have said something more about the Nazi people on everything.
And I go,
Eh,
it's not really my job to be the Adl light.
You know,
plus people have lied about me so I don't even know.
And he goes,
okay,
he was very compassionate and I wish that I had to realize,
yeah,
I do.
There is a problem with antisemitism in America.
The just,
they're just subject,
there's been shootings now.
So that seems like an obvious thing to say.
And I,
and the problem,
Trump should come out more strongly against it,
but then the medial say Trump admits his supporters and I summarize,
right?
So if you're a journalist and you actually give a fuck and you actually want to
make the world a better place,
you would give room for people like Trump to say,
I didn't realize this was a problem.
It's a fucking problem.
And if you're about that life,
you need to get away from me.
And if you could just say,
okay,
Trump,
clear stance,
you guys antisemitism.
If that were the story,
did the incentive structure would be to,
to create that.
But I'm saying that he hasn't done that or that they won't acknowledge it.
He's done it cause he's done it to the idea that he's an anti Semitism no,
no.
The idea is,
and it isn't.
Um,
but I think a,
a just a real clear,
strong condemnation along with,
if you're about that life,
I don't want your votes,
don't come to my rallies,
just stay away from me.
And then the media,
they're still going to lie.
There's still going to spend,
they're still going to talk about dog whistles.
But that's something I wish I had done sooner.
The Islamophobia.
Um,
I,
that's why,
you know,
I've just been very clear about it.
I remember I was at my own event in DC and I was like,
oh,
people are talking about is I'm on my guy,
you know,
whatever is moderate Islam.
And people are like,
there's no such thing as a moderate Islam and my own event,
people are like yelling at me because there's pro.
So I'm like,
okay,
you know,
this is okay or not the Adl light.
I don't need to be tweeting about Islamophobia everyday.
You're gonna Semitism everyday or whatever the issue is every day.
But really do think that as,
and this is the left to call out the,
I want to kill white people.
Bullshit too.
If you are a public figure and you're in your eye,
a leader,
act like a leader.
And if you see bad trends developing,
hey,
it's okay.
Just be very clear about it.
Be Clear that you're not cool with that.
You're not down with that.
Try to steer the world and a little bit of a better direction and know that this
is going to take a long time.
Yeah.
All right man.
Well on that note,
I hope we cleaned up some of this.
The chips will fall where they may and uh,
we'll both keep going I suppose.
And my pleasure.
Thanks again.
Yeah,
good talking to Ya.
And uh,
make sure you're subscribed to our channel.
We,
we crossed the million subscribers this week.
I normally don't do promos.
I meant they're not a promo.
We crossed a million subscribers this week,
but they're just crushing us on the algorithm and the unsubscribed and all that
nonsense.
So make sure you're subscribed.
Click that little bell.
Thanks for watching.
This will be up as a podcast audio podcast later this afternoon,
and,
uh,
we're back to the regularly scheduled programming next week.
Thanks everybody.